- Hey, so unsurprisingly,
this video is probably
going to be covering a lot
of not advertiser friendly things.
- So if you want to check out
the full uncensored version,
head over to our Patreon.
We don't know what we're
gonna be talking about yet,
but I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be pretty spicy.
- And concerning the
guest that we have today,
it's probably gonna be spicy,
so if you'd like to check
out uncensored version,
patreon.com/trashtaste,
links in the description.
Anyway, let's start.
(energetic music)
Hello, you cultured gentlemen, ladies.
I don't care what gender you
are. You're all cultured.
Welcome to "Trash Taste".
- Every gender.
- We welcome every gender.
- As long as you are cultured,
we welcome every-
- That's our agenda.
- That is our agenda.
There are three genders.
I'm Joey, and I'm with the boys as usual,
and we have a special guest.
Introduce yourself.
- Hello. My name is Shindo
L, and I do a manga.
- What kind of manga?
- Yeah, there we go.
There we go.
There we go, that's what's up.
- Is that how you introduce
yourself to, you know,
some fellows of the public
who might not be so
familiar with you work?
- I used to, I just
used to say eromangaka,
and then people start saying,
"You don't have to say the ero part."
- Mangaka's fine.
- Mangaka's fine. Like, okay, manga.
- What do you say when they ask,
"Oh, what kind of series you draw?
Oh, I haven't heard of you.
I haven't heard of you."
- Well then I go, "Yeah, eromanga."
- Ah, okay.
- Okay. Okay.
- Do they normally just stop there.
They're like, "Oh, I kind of get it.
I'm not gonna push too much on this."
- Some people do, some people are curious.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like the same,
it's like porn directors
who are just like, "I'm a porn director."
"You could have just said director."
- [Connor] I make movies.
- Yeah, you could have
just sent you made movies.
That's fine.
- Yeah, I think it's fair to say,
I know the least about you and your work.
I think these two know the most.
- Yeah.
- But I'm sure there are many viewers
who also are in the same position as me,
where they saw your name in
the title, and they're like,
"I don't really know
what it is that you do."
- [Shindo] Yeah.
- So is it some series that
maybe the viewers might know,
and if not, I guess they'll get an insight
into the life of an eromangaka today.
- Well, when I got invited
to talk on "Trash Taste",
I did some homework.
- Oh, okay.
- And I saw the episode where
you guys read my "Henshin".
- Yeah.
- And I know Connor doesn't
think too highly of it.
- This man got caught in 4K, dude.
- I didn't know when
we'd be reviewing stuff
that the authors and makers would come in
and talk to me about it.
- Oh yeah, that's pretty shit.
- I have no words.
Okay, I guess we'll jump right into it.
Okay.
- Yeah.
- You created "Metamorphosis", right?
- I did.
- Very, very popular
in the communities.
- Definitely the most
infamous doujin, I'd say.
- Well one of the most infamous doujins
of all time, I would say,
it's especially in the Western community.
- I said something about
it that I do actually,
I do regret saying.
- Really? Now you do.
- Now you do.
- That's so two faced.
- My opinions on it haven't changed.
There's one thing that I think I did
just get massively wrong.
In the episode, I think I said something
along the lines of like,
it seemed unrealistic that the mom
would blame the daughter for the dad.
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- Kind of thing.
And then I found out it's
totally not unrealistic
and that it's happened a bunch,
and then I lost a lot of faith in humanity
when I found that out.
- Oh yeah. People are fucked.
- Who would've thought?
- I feel like this is just
my child innocent brain.
I'm like, "No, a mom
would never blame the..."
So, okay.
- Oh, you sweet summer child.
- So I guess we should.
- This is like a "Trash Taste" first,
never before has a guest come on and said,
"I heard you were talking shit."
- Yeah.
I might get smacked.
I'm like, "Alright, get the bell out."
- Shindo L just smacked
the shit out of me.
- I guess there's a lot of
things that we just covered.
So yeah, should we
explain, I guess, what...
We're gonna do a montage
immediately now...
What "Metamorphosis" is,
kind of, very lightly,
and then we'll talk in
depth more a little bit.
- So how would you, if
someone asks you like,
"Oh, I've heard this "Metamorphosis"
thing, "Henshin" thing,
but I've never read it,
could you sell it to me?"
What is it about?
- god, it's like "Requiem
For A Dream", but like manga.
- Oh, okay.
- That's probably the best
way to explain it, honestly.
- That is honestly how I
would explain it as well.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I believe I said
something very similar
on the podcast episode
where we described it,
where I was like,
"Yeah, it kind of reminds
me of "Requiem For A Dream",
where it's just really depressing,
but also there's a lot of sex in it.
- Yeah, it's like Requiem For-
- More ass to ass.
- Ass to ass, baby.
- It's "Requiem For a Dream",
but if it was only that scene.
That's probably the best
way to explain it, honestly.
- Literally, the last time
I read it was that episode,
so I'm trying to remember what happens.
It's like a high school girl
meets a guy on the street
and then they hook up and have sex in a-
- Yeah, in a karaoke.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I feel like, why am I
trying to explain your plot?
I'm like, tell me if I'm right here.
And it just keeps escalating
and escalating, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. So like-
- Very adult, by the way.
- Okay I guess we're
jumping right into it now.
- [Shindo] Yeah. Okay.
- How did you come up with that?
I've just got to ask.
What were your inspirations
in writing that?
- Well, it's a trope, right?
First of all, it's the makeover trope.
- Yeah.
- So the girl takes off the
glasses, and she's hot, right?
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- And then there's the Haruka.
- Turning into a, yeah.
- Turning into.
Right.
And I've never drawn
that before, so I'm like,
let's try it out, and...
- And it worked out pretty well.
- That's how it turned out. Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Damn.
- Did you know how the
story was going to develop
before you started working on it,
or was it just something...
'cause it's a pretty long story,
in terms of like a lot of eromanga
compared to some one shorts
or one or two chapters,
but this one was I believe-
- It's a full volume.
- Yeah. It was a full volume.
Did you have everything
planned out from the get go
or did it kind of develop as you wrote it?
- I didn't everything planned out,
but I think I said in the afterword
that I had the ending
out before I started.
- Right.
- And I think I just,
and I was talking to my editors about it,
and they ask, "So how does it end?"
I'm like, "Well, I just
want her to die at the end."
And they're like, "Oh."
- Spoilers, by the way.
- I'm gonna be honest,
I forgot that happened.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think I was so traumatized
at the thing before
I was like, "What the fuck?"
- Yeah, I feel like her, unfortunately,
dying was one of the high points
because her suffering had
ended by that point, right?
- Yeah.
- Right.
And that's like,
did you always know you wanted
it to be that depressing?
- I mean, I wanted it
to be more depressing,
but my editor was like-
- You wanted it to be-
- You have to put like a
little bit of levity in it.
I'm like.
- Wait, hold on.
What did you have to cut
that would've made it more depressing?
- Like, well, I couldn't
put as many drug scenes in
as I wanted to.
- Right, right.
- Because in the magazine,
because it gets published
in the monthly magazine.
- Right, right, right.
- And in the magazine they had to cover up
all the drug bits.
- Oh.
- So a syringe had to be
like, had a blur on it.
- Oh, okay.
- Which would've been normal.
- Yeah, I had the whole cooking up the,
cooking up the drugs.
- Oh wow.
- And they're like, "You can't do that."
- Oh yeah.
- Because the cops are already
kind of tough on eromanga.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they don't want like more pressure.
- Right. Right.
Because it was certainly
rare to see drug use
in just like eromanga,
or just manga in general,
and it was such a heavy theme,
which I think is super, super rare to see
in any kind of media that
comes out from Japan.
- Right, I think seinin
manga, you see some drug use,
like Ushijima-kun or something.
- Yeah.
- But in hentai, it's mostly like...
I don't know what it is.
Right now, it's-
- It's like aphrodisiacs.
- Aphrodisiacs.
- Yeah.
- Like hypnosis apps and stuff like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You have the smartphone app.
- Yeah. The smartphone app, yeah.
- "You are now horny."
Because again, I didn't
know anything about you.
The only work I'd read
was "Metamorphosis",
and I guess, I didn't
know when they were like,
"Oh, Shindo L's coming on."
I'm like, "Oh, does
Shindo L speak English?"
I didn't even know, right.
I didn't know anything.
I guess when you made "Metamorphosis",
do you find that your experiences from...
because you were raised in the US, right?
- [Shindo] Right.
- Yeah.
- Does that have a lot of
effect on how you write manga
or is it still very like Japanese?
- I don't know.
I think, because I've been
told that it's not Japanese.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- Like my storytelling, but
I try to make it Japanese.
- Yeah.
- And I don't know if my
experiences in New York
really helped me.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- I'm sure you've seen a lot
of fucked up stuff in New York.
- I've seen a lot of
fucked up shit, but like,
I try not to directly put
that into my storytelling.
- Mmm.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It would kind of be alien
to most Japanese readers.
- I'm just projecting all the
Florida man stuff I've seen.
You've see a Florida man thing, right?
That's gotta be in one of them.
- I mean, I'm sure that's also the case
considering that I think for
a lot of Japanese people,
New York is kind of like seen
in this like glory light type of like,
like, "New York. Wow."
- It's either like the gritty
New York, or '80s New York,
where it's like you get stabbed.
- Yeah.
- And no one gives a shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Oh my god. Just "Metamorphosis" man.
Did you expect it to be as big?
- I didn't expect it to be so meme-y.
- Yeah. Right.
I knew of the image of
her wearing the glasses,
because as an anime fan,
there's some images
that are almost iconic.
- Yeah.
- And one of them is the
girl with the glasses
and then you're like, "Oh,
if you know, you know."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But, oh my god.
- Yeah, when you released
it, was it something
that immediately got
picked up by the community,
or was it something that you released,
and you had the usual reaction,
and then over time it just
blew up in popularity?
- I think it was an overtime thing,
because when it was in
the magazines, it was...
because the editors didn't
want it to put it up front,
because it's kind of shady.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So it was always at the back.
- Oh, oh.
- Damn.
Trying to push it under the rug.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- So it was kind of low key
for a while until people,
I think online, just picked it up,
and started memeing on it.
- Yeah, because I remember
when I interviewed you
three or four years ago,
I asked if you know the
memes, and you were like,
"Oh yeah, I'm very up
to date on the memes."
Because it's just like, I don't know,
do you think the memes
like kind of, I don't know,
take away from like the message
that you were trying to
portray in "Metamorphosis",
or do you think just like kind of just,
"Nah, I enjoy the memes. It's whatever."
- The memes are fine.
I don't think about putting out a message
when I make a story.
- Right, right, right.
- Just something you wanna talk about?
- Yeah, I mean, I just wanted
to make it entertaining
first and foremost.
- Yeah.
- But I think a lot of-
- I'm don't know if I feel
entertained, I feel something.
- Well, you know, a car
crash is entertaining.
- Yeah.
- But I think though, regardless,
I think like a lot of
people read "Metamorphosis"
and was like,
"There's some hidden message here.
There's some kind of deeper
meaning to this like story."
Because it's just so different
to the standard doujins
you would read, right?
- Yeah.
- Like, the normal doujin
is just like, boy meets
girl, boy fucks girl.
- Yeah.
- That's kind of it, you know.
I mean, I would say out of
every erodoujin I've seen,
or eromanga,
I was probably the most
invested in any story
as I was in...
I wasn't as invested in any other story
as I was in "Metamorphosis",
in terms of just seeing
the characters develop
in the development that you gave them,
and just, a lot of things
outside of just the hentai scenes
and the sex scenes, and everything,
I was properly invested in
the characters and the ending,
and that also also made
me even more invested
in the eroscenes as well.
I thought that was fantastic.
I dunno how much of it
was planned on your end,
but it was absolutely incredible.
- Well, as long as this is like
a seed of a story in there,
I think people would pick up on it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because a lot of hentai, I think,
especially since maybe early 2000s,
they've been streamlining
it to make it more like,
I don't know, fappable.
- Yeah. I've noticed.
- They just jump straight
into the fucking,
and I'm just like, "Come on, guys."
- They're are some doujins
I've read where I'm like,
I feel like I've skipped five pages.
- Yeah.
- Because there is no buildup.
- Yeah, when I open a doujin it's like,
page two, or even page one.
- Page one.
- Come on, guys.
- Yeah, page one, and
they're already fucking.
I'm like, "Whoa, whoa."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "Chill out. Ease me
into this shit, god damn."
- I'll take that over the hentai
that start with three minutes
of text, explaining the story.
Who thought that was a good idea?
- No, but some people are
super into that, right?
It's like-
- No.
- Yeah, they are.
- What, it's like "Star
Wars" text on screen.
- Yeah, some movies just
start out with a monologue.
- What is happening?
- It's the same people who
enjoy the interview sections
at the start of porn, right?
They wanna get into the story beforehand.
It's like, "I wanna feel
invested in this, you know?"
- Yeah, I have noticed another trend
that I've seen with a
lot of eromanga recently,
or just not even recently.
It's, you know where they say
the most important part of a YouTube video
is the first 14 seconds?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So like there are some eromanga
that start off with just the fucking
for the first three pages,
and then it goes to the story.
Like you've gonna hook the viewers.
- Yeah, it's almost like
page one they're fucking,
and then it's like, "This
is how it happened."
- There's like an eromanga algorithm.
- It's like AI generators.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I'm very interested to know,
so you lived in New York, right?
- Yeah.
- How do you then go
from living in New York to being like,
"Oh, I'm gonna start
drawing eromanga in Japan."
How is that a transition that happens?
- Well, I've always been drawing.
- [Connor] Right, right, right.
- And when you're a kid, you wanna like,
"I wanna go up and I just wanna draw."
Right.
- Right, right.
- And after college I'm like,
"Okay, how do I do that?"
- [Connor] Right, right.
- And like, I could start in the US,
but then there's the comics
industry, and it's kind of like,
it's kind of a, well, it's
never, you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- It's like, you have
to do this sort of work.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And if you wanna branch
off, it's really minor.
It's super underground.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just like a furry porn
section, but it's like-
- That's how you make money, right?
- Exactly.
- If you wanna be a freelance.
- They're loaded.
- Just browse DeviantArt.
- But if you go to Japan,
it's like this huge...
And back then, like mid 2000s,
there was hardly any download manga.
- Yeah.
- Right. Right.
- There was like DLsite,
maybe, and that's about it.
- Mm.
- So I'm like, that's a low bar to reach.
- Yeah.
- Just upload stuff,
and sell it, and it's like, "Fuck."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's great.
- I mean, I guess it was like the closest
to having an independent scene.
- [Shindo] Right.
- Where you could just
easily upload and just kind
of get your work out there
instead of like having to go
through so many publishers
and getting picked up and stuff like that.
- Exactly.
- And I guess a good way to
grow organically as well, right.
- Yeah.
- Because those kinds of works
are just spread by word of mouth.
- Yeah.
- So you were always
able to speak Japanese as a kid?
- Oh, I had to work on it.
- Oh, yeah, okay.
- I spoke it.
- Yeah.
- But I couldn't read or write too well.
- Oh, okay.
- So, it's like,
and if you ever saw those, I don't know,
if you've met like a bad translation,
you know what I'm talking about.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know.
- It's like bad translations.
- I have to work, so I spent a lot of time
just playing video games.
- Oh, okay.
- And reading novels and stuff.
- Research, it's research.
- Yeah.
It helped me out, you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you were doing it...
Have you always been self-published
or did you come to Japan self-published.
- I came to Japan self-published
and then a publisher picked up on it.
- [Connor] Oh, okay.
- It's like, "Hey, you
wanna draw for a magazine?"
I'm like, "Sure. Why not?"
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
So, why did you choose to be
on the ero side of things then?
- Well, I've always been
interested in the ero side.
That's-
- How did you get into the ero side?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because I feel every
eromanga artist always kind of,
their beginnings are always different.
- Oh yeah.
- Right.
- Well, my beginnings were like,
my first doujin was a
"Planet of the Apes"...
- No.
- You are fucking kidding?
- Eromanga parody.
- Okay. Okay.
- Wait, wait, wait.
- What made you wanna do it? Like Caesar?
- Yeah, like Dr. Seuss.
- I wanna read that now.
- Oh my god.
- Wait, wait, so how did
that idea come about?
You were just watching
"Planet of the Apes" one day
and you were like, "I
can make this hotter."
- I remember seeing a porno
that was like a "Planet
of the Apes" ripoff.
- No?
- Back when I was a teenager,
and I'm like, it just stuck in my head.
- Yeah. I bet.
- I was like, "What the fuck was that?"
And it was just eating
away at me, and I was like,
"I have to draw this," and
like, I just put that out.
- Wow.
- My god.
- "Planet of the Gapes".
That's probably what it was called.
- I don't know if this is inaccurate.
Did it do well? Did people like it?
- Oh, it did not do well.
- I was gonna say, I mean,
it's kind of furry, but-
- It was just a comic,
and I sold 70 copies.
- I mean, I'm surprised
there's an audience.
If you asked me how many
people I think would buy
a "Planet of the Apes" doujin.
- That's 70 more people than
I thought it was going to be.
Jesus Christ.
- But I printed a thousand copies.
- Jesus.
- I was gonna like print a
hundred, but then it's like,
if you're gonna print a hundred,
it only costs like so much
more to print a thousand.
- So what happened to these
copies? Where are they?
- They stuck with me for a while.
Every time I go to a Comiket,
I just like put a little bit out.
- Oh, okay.
- Okay.
- So after 10, 12 years,
I finally got rid of them.
- Background.
- Genius recycling.
- Now it's just like a rare item now.
Because now I'm fucking curious.
I want that. I want this.
That sounds incredible.
- It's like a bonus item at Comiket now.
- So how old were you when you drew
this "Planet of the Apes"?
- Oh my god, like 20 something.
23.
- Oh no.
- It's just such a bizarre start.
- That's that's the most
bizarre origin story
I've ever heard.
The "Planet of the Apes".
That sounds like a meme.
Like, "Tell me how you got into-T
- It doesn't sound real.
- "Tell me how you got into hentai."
"Oh, 'Planet of the Apes', of course."
- "So there's just movie
called 'Planet of the Apes', right?"
- So after "Planet of the
Apes", what came next?
Dare I ask?
- I mean, after that,
it's pretty standard.
There's a Dragon Quest.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Oh yeah, yeah. I've seen that one.
- A Japanese's favorite.
- Very popular. Yeah.
- And that's when my first
editor came to me and like,
"Hey, this is pretty nice."
- Right, right. Okay.
- Yeah, I gotta ask, as an ero artist,
how do you choose, aside
from your original work,
how do you decide to choose
which works to draw porn about,
I guess.
Do you go with the algorithm to be like,
"Okay, there's a bunch of...
This is hot right now. This
is hot commodity right now."
Or do you just go with
whatever you are a fan of?
- I think my primary motivation
is drawing stuff that I want
to read, but isn't available.
- Oh.
- You know?
- Okay, okay, okay.
- It's like, if someone drew
it, I wouldn't draw at all.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's literally the, "Fuck
it, I'll do it myself" method.
- I imagine the "Planet of the
Apes" doujin market wasn't-
- There wasn't much of a market there.
- You are the market.
- "I'll create the market myself."
- Oh, that's awesome.
- You found like the 70 people that wanted
a "Planet of the Apes"
doujin when it came out.
- And with the "Dragon Quest",
there wasn't anything that
I found satisfying enough.
- Right. Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I have to do it myself.
- Oh, awesome.
How do you develop the
skills to draw H manga
and eromanga specifically?
Did you have to do a lot of practice?
- A lot of research.
- A lot of research. Yeah.
- Research, wink wink.
Did you go to art school
and stuff like that?
- I did a major in art in college.
- Okay.
- Right.
- So there's that, but
it doesn't really help.
- Right. Right.
- I mean, you learn
anatomy and how to paint-
- I mean, I'd argue anatomy is
quite important in eromanga.
- Yeah, yeah.
But, you know, you don't really need it.
- But I'm like, what I'm saying is like,
you don't really see eromanga
in the style of like "Baki".
It's usually, more so
than anything, you know,
like you read the karma
sutra, and you're like,
"Okay, I think I kind of
figured out basic anatomy
and basic positions and stuff like that.
- I think libido's more
important than anatomy.
- That's wise words right there.
- I wanna put that on a shirt.
- Put that on a t-shirt.
Put that on a t-shirt.
- Because you see some
artists, and you know,
hips don't go that wide, or
boobs don't grow that big.
- That's true. That's true.
- But it doesn't matter, because you know,
that's what he's into.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Like how much do you like
to stay, I guess, true to...
what am I trying to say here?
Like-
- A human physique?
- Are you true to the human physique?
- Oh, like I have my own preferences,
but I try to expand them whenever I can.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I'd say your style is
definitely more rooted in reality
than a lot of artists I've seen lately.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, there's a wide variety to-
- Yeah, there is a very wide range
about how artists see the human anatomy,
especially in doujin.
Oh my god.
- Like some artists, I'm just like,
have you ever seen a human in your life?
Like, that is not what humans look like.
- That's what they want, Joey.
- That's what they want though.
- What they want.
- That's what they want, man.
That's what they want. Oh my god.
Yeah, I think, obviously "Metamorphosis"
is one of your biggest series,
but you've had a couple of
other long form as well, right?
Like "TSF", I think it's called.
- "TSF Monogatari".
- Yeah, "TSF Monogatari" is a big one.
There's also the "Dragon
Ball" one I've read of yours.
- Oh, you read the-
- The Broly one. Yeah.
- The doujin.
- Yeah. That one-
- I have not read that one.
- A Broly doujin?
- Yeah, he wrote a Broly doujin.
- The new Broly movie.
- You made a doujin?
- I made a doujin of that.
- Well, that's a step down
from "Planet of the Apes".
All the fur's gone.
- Yeah,
all the fur's gone now.
- All the fur's gone now.
- The personality's there,
but the fur has gone.
- Yeah, that was training art
to do a Dragon Ball doujin.
- Yeah, the Broly one's
sick. I love the Broly one.
- Yeah, it's wholesome, right?
- Yeah, it's really wholesome.
It's just like, Broly being like,
"Oh, there's this thing called sex,
and I need some help with it because.
- He looks like a bad-
- He's literally a 40
year old virgin, right?
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
He's literally like the 40 year old virgin
of the Dragon Ball universe.
- He literally just like fucks everyone.
- Yeah.
- What did I expect?
- Because in the doujin,
he like discovers what a
boner is for the first time,
and he's like, "What is this?
I don't know what this
is. Help, I'm scared.
What do I do? It hurts."
- What gives him a boner, initially?
- I think it was the
Cheelai. Remember Cheelai?
The green skin girl.
- Yeah.
- I think she was masturbating and like,
they were-
- And the guy peeks in.
- "What is she doing?
Something's happening?"
- Oh my god.
- He literally had that reaction
of when you discover porn for
the first time, it's like,
"Oh, what? What's going on?
What's going on in my
pants? What the hell?"
- Yeah.
- World domination.
- [Joey] Yeah, what is this in my pants?
- Oh my god.
- So exciting.
- Yeah, I gotta ask,
what's your creative
process around coming up
with the different concepts
of your different works
and everything like that?
Do you have one, or is it just-
- Whatever I find.
- Sometimes,
sometimes an idea just comes
and you just start drawing?
- Well, sometimes I see a
work of art and I'm like,
like a movie or a novel or
something that I'm reading,
and I'm like, "If there are
only more sex scenes in this."
- I think I've been having
different experiences
watching "Planet of the Apes".
- I guess that's the how-
- Thank you so much.
That's the best thing.
That is genuinely the
best thing I've heard.
- Yeah.
- I guess that's how
"Metamorphosis" happened, right?
Like you're probably watching
"Requiem for a Dream"
or something similar, and you were like-
- This ass to ass scene is way too short.
- I need more, more of this, please.
- No one wants see your
arm getting chopped off,
or someone's mother going insane.
We want the ass to ass.
- The ass to ass. More ass to ass.
- More of that.
Which, now that I think about it,
it basically just was the
storyline of the main heroin,
right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Of "Requiem for a Dream."
Holy shit, I'm just like...
I've just connected that together.
- How many pages was
"Metamorphosis" again?
- Like 250 something, I think.
- Right? Yeah, it's quite long, right?
- Yeah.
- How long would
something like that take?
Because I mean, it's obviously,
reading it, it's like, "Oh,
I can do this kind of fast."
- I do pretty long chapters,
like 40, 50 page chapters.
So...
- I mean, that was
released monthly, right?
- Yeah.
- So how many months
was that? Like a year?
- I think maybe like
six months of storyline.
- Wow.
- Damn.
- Which is.
- That is crazy.
- And I didn't do every month.
I did one every other month.
- Oh yeah, yeah. Right, right.
- Because each chapter takes
maybe like a few hundred hours
of work.
- Geez.
- Hot damn.
- Hello lads.
It's your boy, Joey, here to let you know
that this episode is sponsored by Honey.
Call me a millennial, call me a Zoomer,
but I like shopping online,
and one of the benefits of shopping online
is that you can input
all sorts of promo codes.
But every time I shop online,
that promo code field just taunts me.
If only I could fill it
up with some coupon codes
to save me some money.
Thankfully though, Honey
is here to save the day.
Thanks to Honey, manually
searching for coupon codes
is a thing of the past.
Honey's the free shopping
tool that scours the internet
for promo codes, and applies
the best ones it finds
to your cart.
Okay, the boys aren't here to back me up,
so you be the boys this time, alright.
Just imagine you're shopping online,
and when you check out,
the Honey button appears
and all you have to do
is click "Apply coupons,"
wait a few seconds as
Honey searches for coupons
it can find for that site, and boom,
if honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch the prices drop.
Did you feel that symbiotic energy?
Yeah. That's the Honey effect.
You see this microphone and
microphone stand right here?
Yeah, I managed to get $50
off this massive purchase
thanks to Honey.
And let me just say, if you
don't already have Honey,
you could be just straight
up missing out on savings.
And by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and supporting the show at the same time.
So get Honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Link's in the description below.
Thank you to Honey for
sponsoring this episode.
Onto the show.
- So what's like a day in the
life of an eromanga artist?
- It depends how much work you have.
If you're doing a serialized manga,
then you wake up, you
draw, you go to sleep.
- Right.
- Mm-hmm.
- And you do that for maybe like a month.
- Oh wow.
- Oh, wow.
Do you have like assistants
and stuff like that?
- When I did "Metamorphosis",
I had two assistants,
who did most of the tone work.
- Right, right, right.
- Okay.
Is your office at your home,
or do you have like a dedicated
office where you go to draw?
- It was at my home, so
my living room was like
desks lining the wall.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- And you had to make room
for two other assistants
on top of that?
- Right.
- Oh wow.
- They're just like on the floor.
Just cutting tones out.
That's just like my image of
these kinds of small manga
studios and stuff like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, the assistants are on the floor.
- But you've seen them before.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly, exactly.
- How often do you get to
work on serialized work?
Because I imagine, as you just
said, it takes a lot of work,
so-
- Like whenever I want to.
- Whenever you want to? Yeah.
- After my first tankobon,
what do you call it?
- Like, volume.
- Volume.
- Tankobon?
- Yeah.
- First book, whatever.
- Book.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- After my first book came out,
and it sells pretty well,
then people start asking you to do works.
- Right, right.
- Mm-hmm.
- And after you gain a
little bit of notoriety,
then you don't really have
any trouble finding work.
- Yeah.
- As long as you wanna work, you can.
- Oh, okay.
- So that,
I've been lucky in that sense.
- So you just go on your own schedule?
- Yeah.
- Awesome. Awesome.
- I'm sure you got quite a
bit of notoriety as well,
after "Metamorphosis", right?
- Actually, I think my
first two gave me the most,
what is it, name value.
- Oh.
- Is that including the
"Planet of the Apes" one?
- No, no. My first two, like-
- Oh, books.
- Books.
- Oh, okay, I was about
to say. I was like...
- "Sarashi Ai", and "TSF Monogatari".
- Yeah, right, right, right.
- Like my first two published books.
- Mm-hmm.
- Yeah.
- I've always been curious,
because obviously "Metamorphosis"
has been very memed up
in the Western anime community.
- [Shindo] Right.
- What's the Japanese side of things like?
how's your Japanese audience
reacted to your work?
- I think Japanese audience
finds my work kind of weird.
Because my stuff is a bit
different than the mainstream.
- Yeah, it definitely is. Yeah.
In a good way, I feel. Yeah.
- I mean like it's more
store driven, I think.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Definitely.
- But I just keep trying to
put a lot of hentai in there
to make it work.
- Pay attention, guys. Please, please.
- So, I mean, I think
in the Japanese market,
my most best seller is still my first one.
- Right, right.
- "Sarashi Ai".
Well, that's because it's been out long.
- So the reaction from the
Western and Japanese audience
of "Metamorphosis" was really different?
- Yeah. It's night and day, basically.
- Wow.
- Wow. Okay.
- That's interesting.
- How do you balance
the amount of story you put in a work
versus the amount of sex scene you put in?
- Yeah.
Was I supposed to fap to "Metamorphosis"?
Genuine-
- Genuine question.
- Because I was reading
it and I'm like, I don't,
when would I?
- Maybe like the first three chapters.
- Yeah, yeah,
that's The only point where I felt like...
- The karaoke scene
probably was like the best,
optimal point, yeah.
- And after that, I was like, oh.
I don't know how much it would meme,
the Mr. Incredible meme.
When it just gets more and more sad.
- More sad, yeah.
- Mr. Incredible becomes uncanny.
- That one was very confusing.
I was like, "Is this
more story or more porn?"
I couldn't really...
- Right. Yeah.
- Was it just like, or do
you not see it as that?
It's just like, it is a
story that has porn in it,
you can do what you want.
- I think that's the most optimal way
of having a story with sex in it,
because if you have like
a hentai, and it's like,
there's a story part for
the first five pages,
and then like the next 20 pages is sex.
- I don't have an answer for that.
- What was that?
- What the hell was that?
- That was you.
- Oh, that was me?
Oh.
Sorry.
I dunno why Google thought we said Google.
- So like if there's like
a story part for five pages
and then 20 pages of sex.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- Then you could skip the
story part, can't you,
then you just read the
story and read the sex
and you'd be like, and you're done.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- So is it more that you can't,
in Japan, you can't draw stories
that have a lot of sex in them,
without it being labeled
as like an eromanga?
Like, would you say you're
trying to draw more stories
than trying to draw something
to fap to, in a way?
- I think it's a little bit of both,
but I think it's sexier
if there's a story.
- Right. So it has-
- I agree with that.
- Yes.
- Okay. Okay.
- So your biggest challenge is not
putting story in your work,
but it's incorporating it
in a way that makes it-
- The sex should be an integral
part of the story, I think.
- Okay.
- Thank you.
- Someone who gets it. Thank you.
That's why you're the legend.
- Shindo is the goat.
- Yeah, because you're like
you read some hentai manga
and there is a very like clear distinction
between here's the story
part, and here's the sex part.
- Yeah, because
"Metamorphosis" didn't feel
like a porn thing, for me.
- Yeah.
- It felt like a really
dark story and very adult.
- Yeah.
- I think that's why
it drew so many people in though, right?
- Yeah.
- Because they're probably
going into it expecting it to be
five pages of story,
20 pages of sex scenes,
and then you're like, "Hold on a second."
- But yeah, I'm just wondering now,
because it made me think like,
oh, does Japan have like a...
if it has X amount of sex in it,
would they just automatically
put it in the, oh it's porn?
- Yeah.
- Even if the story
is very fleshed out and very...
- I think there's no like clear cut line
between like porn and
a story with sex in it,
because you see a lot of thing in manga
with a decent amount of sex in it.
- Yeah. True.
- True.
- I think it depends on just
how much you're showing,
right, probably.
- I guess so. Yeah.
- Because a lot of scene
in manga and sex scenes
and stuff like that, it's usually like,
you only see like the top half, or-
- [Connor] Moaning faces.
- Yeah, or just like a moaning face.
- It's whited out.
- Yeah, it's completely
whited out or whatever,
whereas a lot of doujins,
yeah, it's whited out,
but it's like very minimally whited out.
- Yeah.
- You know.
- Do you have an unconscious page count
that you need to reach in terms of like,
"I need to show sex for
this amount of pages."
Because I do notice
that with a lot of manga
where it just feels like,
okay, you have a typical manga,
it's like 20 odd pages,
that's like five pages of
story and dialogue, maybe,
and then 15 pages of sex.
- I think if you have an editor,
they try to give you a
set limit of how much-
- They're like, "Chill, my
dick can only get so hard."
- So if you're making a 30 page manga-
- Yeah.
- Your editor would say, at
least 20 pages should be sex.
- What?
- Wow.
- So if you're working
under those restrictions,
it's hard to make a good story.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because you only have 10 pages of story.
- [Garnt] You have 10 pages of story.
- That's why if you incorporate
the story into the sex,
then you have all those
pages to work with.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I feel like that just makes
the work better in general,
if you find a way to
incorporate it somehow.
- [Shindo] Right.
- But I guess it's hard because,
one, so few other mangakas do it,
and two, I guess you
really need to think about
what kind of scenarios
really work in terms of just
here is a scenario that is
just not a baseline scenario
of just like, "Oh, sorry, big brother.
I got like stuck in the
washing machine," or something.
- That is sick.
- What is that? How's that work out?
- Yeah, exactly, yeah.
- Are there any tropes that
you really hate seeing?
- Oh, I mean,
I don't hate anything, really.
It's, for me, the execution.
- Okay. I see.
So it's not so much the
device, more what's used.
- Yeah.
- That makes sense.
- [Joey] Mm.
- What are some of your
least favorite tropes
you've seen in hentai
manga, or in your field?
- Or maybe like a trope you
would never personally use.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Oh, I don't know,
walking into like a girl
bathing, slipping, and,
"Oh,"
catching yourself by the boobies.
- So basically every scene in "Tawawa".
The entirety of "Tawawa".
- That goes beyond just like hentai manga.
That's just like manga in general.
- That's just manga in general, right?
- Yeah.
- It does get old very fast.
- But it's a classic, though.
- It's a classic, but it's like,
I feel there are, especially
some H manga that is just like,
every chance they can get is like,
so we have this new girl character.
- Yeah.
- How do we introduce her to the audience?
- A bath scene.
- They better be stinky,
because they're going
in the bath right now.
- Yeah.
- How much research you have to do
for when you work on something?
- You have to say research.
- Because it is research, man.
It's the only guy I could talk to
and ask if it's actually research,
because it is research.
- It is research. Yeah.
- The more you do the better, because...
there's so much work out
there that there's always
some kind of new way of showing a scene,
or a new angle, or a new device,
of showing a whatever.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That, you could always
incorporate into your work.
So you should always read
other people's stuff.
- I mean, yeah, porn makes Marvel's output
look like nothing.
- Yeah.
- There's so much out
there. It seems it's insane.
- Especially the doujin scene in Japan.
It's crazy, every time. Yeah.
- Why are there so many Transformer ones?
- I don't know.
- There's a lot of
Transformer, which I dunno.
- I have noticed that, actually.
- Every time I've gone in the stores,
there's like 15 Optimus
Prime getting boned.
- People find Transformers
sexy. I don't know.
I mean.
- Bumblebee does pee on someone.
I guess that's ero fueled.
- Yeah, I've noticed there's
a lot of Transformers
and "Sailor Moon".
- "Sailor Moon" makes a lot of sense.
- Yeah, "Sailor Moon" makes sense.
- "Sailor Moon" makes more sense. Yeah.
- It's hard to find
people doing "Sailor Moon"
these days, though.
- I dunno, I still find a lot of like,
I don't know if they're new, necessarily.
- What's the most popular
ones now, ones to make doujin?
- Well there's always the
people who do the newest thing.
- "Demon Slayer".
- "Demon Slayer". "Fate".
It's always popular.
- It's always popular, yeah.
- Any of the idols. "Idolmaster".
- Yeah, one that's big right now
is like "Blue Archive" stuff.
- Oh yeah.
- That one.
There's a lot of that.
- Can you explain to me how
the doujin rules or laws
work in Japan?
Because like everyone knows
that Japanese copyright laws
are non-existent, they don't...
there's no fair use or anything like that,
but it seems to be like
doujins have been like,
alright, we'll let you slide.
- There's an honor code, basically.
- [Connor] Okay. Okay.
- Where if the original
copyright holder says no doujins,
you shouldn't do any doujins.
- If they don't say
anything, it's fair game?
- [Shindo] If they don't
say anything it's fair game.
- Okay.
- Oh wow.
So they kind of just like turn
the blind eye or something?
- Yeah, basically.
I mean recently, there's
been "Uma Musume".
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And they said, "No doujins."
- Oh, wow.
- Oh really?
- So people don't it.
- Oh wow.
- Okay.
- Almost feels like a
waste not to, though.
- Yeah, you think that's
like the one series-
- "Uma Musume" as well?
- Yeah, that's like waifus galore, right,
for a lot of the fans,
so you'd think there'd be like
a massive market for that.
- Well it's based on
like real life voices.
- Oh.
- So, you know,
it's kinda like, you don't want-
- I guess weird politics come in to that.
- Right, it's like my baby.
I don't wanna see my baby kind of like-
- Yeah.
- Better stick to apes, right?
- Horses, overrated.
Apes, though?
- Apes are where it's at.
- That's real shit right there.
I can't get over that. I
really wanna read that.
- Yeah, so how much of your
work goes into preparing
for basically Comiket,
and how much is it just in
general trying to appeal
to just the mass audience
and putting your work online nowadays?
- Well, back when you
know there was Comiket-
- Yeah, yeah. RIP.
- You know, twice a year,
that's like the main bread and
butter of your doujin work.
- Mm-hmm.
- Right, right, right.
- So, two of these,
and then that was pretty much,
like, if you're a moderately
successful doujin artist,
then Comiket twice a year,
you could live off of it.
- Right.
- Damn.
- Okay.
- Wow.
- So people usually do that,
and then other doujin events on the side
or magazine work on the side.
- Yeah.
How hard is it to get a
booth or a table at Comiket?
What's the prices of that one?
- Comiket, by the way, is
like Japanese Comic Con.
It's massive.
- Right. Comic market.
Very huge.
- Comic market.
- Very huge.
- It's like what, 300,
400,000 people or something.
- It's insane.
It's the biggest
convention, right, by far?
- I think it's one of the
biggest conventions in the world.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
And it's all doujin.
- Yeah, it's all doujin.
- All doujin?
- It's all doujin. Yeah.
It's not like-
- It's not all hentai.
It's every kind of doujin.
- 'Cause doujin just means-
- Self-published.
- Self-published stuff.
- Yeah.
- So like a lot of like.
- I learned that
from "Trash Taste" as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
So there's like entire sections of Comiket
where it's just like the
non ero stuff, right?
- Yeah, it's like just like
novels, or music, or whatever.
- That's so cool, though,
that that can attract that many people.
- Yeah.
- I feel like if there's
a convention like that
in the US or the UK,
I don't think it would be nearly as big.
- Well, because it's, anime is just
a lot less accessible over there.
- True. True.
- You know.
If they want the same kind of
anime convention experience
here in Japan, you just go to Akihabara.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- So I can understand
why there is this market
for this here,
but it seems like, like you said,
a lot of livelihoods depend
on the two main Comikets.
- [Shindo] Right.
- So how hard is it to get a booth there
or to be a part of that event?
- If you are established,
then you get like a,
I think you get priority seating.
- Right.
- If you've been to Comiket before,
and you've been consistently
putting stuff out,
they'll look favorably on you
and give your space, usually,
but if you're new, the it's
a dice throw, basically.
- Do you have to know someone?
- No, I mean, it really is pretty random.
- Oh, okay.
- Wow. It's gotcha.
- It's gotcha.
- A lot of ticketed events in
Japan are just lottery, right?
- It is. right.
- So it's completely luck.
- Yeah.
- Which sucks, because it's
like, "Well, I was here first.
Can I have a ticket, please?
- Yeah, you'd think it's
like first come first serve.
- Yeah.
- How did you get your
first booth in Comikets?
- I just applied.
- You just applied?
- Yeah.
- And then he rolled the S.
- And he rolled the SSR.
- He rolled the SSR, dude.
- So if you are not established at all
and you go to Comiket-
- Right?
- How are you getting people
to come stop by the booth
or check it out?
- I mean, people walk by, and you're like,
"Hey, take a look at my stuff,"
and then that's how you have to do it.
- But I think there's also
like a lot of Comiket goers
who are just there to purely
consume all the new shit.
- Yeah.
- And they're kind of there
as like scouts, almost,
to be like, you know...
- How many tables are we
talking? How many salons?
- Oh my god. I have no idea.
- Like thousands.
- A lot.
- Oh my god.
Yeah, so it feels like
if you haven't made a name for yourself,
how on earth would you stand out
if there's thousands of people?
- I mean, if you're seeing
like a picture of Comiket,
it's like a sea of people,
and you get drowned out easily,
so it's just like, you have
to hope someone walks by
and takes at look at your stuff.
- It's literally like
busking on the street, right,
it's just you just have to hope
that you are drawing enough,
you just have to hope you're
drawing enough attention
where someone will stop to listen.
- Well nowadays there's Twitter and other-
- Right, right, right.
- You can have online presence
before you do Comiket.
- Yeah.
- How important is that as an ero artist?
- I'm pretty old school,
so it doesn't matter.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because I started before Twitter.
- Right. Right.
- So-
- Yeah, I guess you
were already established
before the social media thing, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
I think nowadays, if you're starting,
it's definitely important to have
some kind of online presence.
- And I feel that just,
especially on Twitter,
that community, as well,
is really supportive
of other artists.
I see doujin artists I follow on Twitter
retweeting other doujin
artists all the time.
- Yeah, so Joey does.
- I don't retweet any of it, mind you.
I only like it.
It just appears on your
timeline, that's all.
- Yeah, I think I followed two
doujin artists or something,
at the start, and then just
by following one or two,
my entire timeline was filled
with hentai, because they-
- Because they're constantly
retweeting each other's stuff.
Right?
- Yeah.
- Twitter must know, as well,
when you scroll and stop for a moment,
I feel like it knows, because it starts...
- Oh yeah.
- It keeps pushing it.
- "So you want more of this, right?"
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- You spend more than two seconds on this.
- Yeah.
It's like, you stopped
scrolling for five seconds,
and didn't like.
Well, we see you.
- But doujin Twitter is
really wholesome though.
Like people are really
supportive of each other.
- It is, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, really supportive.
- Always, you hear
Twitter's like a cesspool,
but you don't really see
it if you're doing doujin.
- Yeah.
- Well that's why
half the people I follow on
Twitter are just doujin artists,
because I don't wanna see that
other fucking horror cesspool
of Twitter.
- Yeah.
It's like the Pornhub
comment section, right,
which is like the most
wholesome comment section
you will find on the internet.
- It's like, "Yes, King,
thank you for your input.
Appreciate it.
W plus I care."
- Everyone's got too much
post-nut clarity to like-
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'm empty.
Truly focused. Truly enlightened.
- I care, plus I asked.
- Yeah.
I guess have you, have
you ever thought about
putting more effort into
having a bigger online presence
and maybe growing your audience there
and getting an audience
that will support a Patreon,
or like a-
- I have a Patreon, but I'm
really bad at updating it.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because I'm just too...
I'm lazy first of all,
but like when I get into
like drawing something,
if I start working on a project,
then I'm too focused on
it to do anything else.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So updating a weekly
thing is like, oh god,
I have to spend hours
doing that instead of this.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What about stuff like,
do you have like a Skeb,
or anything like that?
- No, not at the moment.
- Have you thought about it?
- I'd like to,
but then it's more stuff I have to take.
- Ah, yeah, that's true. That's true.
- Do you wanna explain what Skeb is?
- Skeb is basically like Fiverr,
where you can like
commission artists to draw
whatever it is you want,
and I think in like recent times,
Skeb has like really
gotten massive overseas,
just 'cause a lot of
independent VTubers, especially,
hire Japanese artists, because it's like,
"I'm a virtual anime girl,
who am I gonna get to
draw a virtual anime girl?
Probably an anime artist
with an anime style."
Right, so that's like
really blown up recently,
and like I know a lot
of independent artists
and doujin artists like live
purely off of Skeb commissions.
Right?
- Oh yeah.
- Some artists make bank off Skeb.
- I figure.
- Yeah.
I mean, there's a lot of porn on Skeb.
Like, a lot of porn there.
- There is.
- It's like an insane
amount of porn on Skeb.
- There is a lot of porn,
a lot of porn that can be commissioned
by very, very talented artists.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- The disparity between
the work you see on Fiverr
and the work you see on
Skeb is like night and day.
- Oh dude, not even a comparison.
- Yeah.
- It's crazy how good.
- Yeah, if you want to
go commission good arts,
and good artists, go on Skeb.
- And like Skeb has a feature now where
even if you write the
commission in English,
it auto translates to Japanese.
- Oh it does actually.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So like a lot of Japanese artists now,
you don't have to write
in like broken Japanese,
the auto translate thing.
Yeah, you don't have to be like,
"Konichiwa. Commission please."
You don't have to be like that now.
So yeah, because I know a lot
of my English speaking friends
who don't know a word of Japanese
just commission a bunch
of Japanese artists
and they get exactly what they want.
- Oh cool.
- Yeah, yeah, so it's really cool.
They really optimize that.
- Yeah, in the hentai world,
do you find like that there
is like ever certain trends
or a meta that gets popular
between different artists, or...
I'm so curious what the
world is like, basically.
- Oh yeah.
I mean, sometimes there's,
I can't think of a good example.
Like, oh, recently, not too
recently, a couple of years ago
there was a meta that was
going around that was like
a fixed camera, and so for a few panels,
it's like for a few pages,
it's the same angle.
- Oh.
- Oh, I remember that.
- There's like a time lapse.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Holy shit.
- It's like 11:00 AM.
They're in missionary.
And then it's like 2:00
AM, they're in doggy.
- Right.
- And it's the same angle.
- They take a water break.
- Oh my god, that is...
- You know what it reminds me of,
it reminds me of that
fight scene an "Old Boy"
where it's just like one static camera,
but then you just
extrapolate that with sex,
and that was just that meta.
Oh my god. That's so weird.
I never knew that was like...
- But you'll notice it now.
- Yeah, yeah, I know it now
that you said it, I noticed it.
I remember.
- It's like
there was montages in late '80s films
where it's like time
lapsing, except it's sex.
Oh my god.
Yeah, now that you say that,
I've read so many doujins that used that.
- Yeah.
- Recently. Oh my god.
I never thought about that.
That's crazy.
- Yeah, because, I dunno,
how often do you try to
break out of the trend,
or do something original,
or do you sometimes read
some works and you're like,
"Damn, that's awesome.
I gotta incorporate it
in my own work as well."
- Well,
I don't know if I'm weird or not,
but it has to interest me,
or else I'm not gonna have fun drawing it,
and if I'm not gonna have fun drawing it,
then I don't do it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Of course. Of course.
- You gotta put your passion in.
- Yeah, well some people
are really professional
and they just like,
"I draw what I'm asked," you know?
- Or you draw what's
hot, currently, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I can't really bring
myself to doing any of that,
so if it doesn't really spark
interest in me, spark joy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Then I can't do it.
- Yeah.
- Spark joy.
It's like, if I'm not drawing it,
I don't have a big smile on my face,
then it ain't it.
- So like-
- I respect that.
- If I wanted to do like a straight up
boy meets girl kind of story,
then I have to put my own twist on it,
otherwise it's not interesting to me.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- What would the Shindo L twist
be in an instance like that?
- I remember doing one
basically straightforward story,
which is just like one guy
and one girl just having sex.
- Just a vanilla type. Yeah.
- And I think I made the
girl a quadruple amputee.
- For what purpose?
- I mean like, why not, right?
- Alright. Fair enough.
- So that's the most vanilla
we're gonna get out you.
- That's right.
- So to explain, she had no arms, no legs.
- She had no arms, no legs.
- Okay.
I feel like that's like, as something...
did you read a lot of
Asanagi during that time?
- I read Asanagi,
but it was a really
wholesome story though.
Yeah.
- It's like...
just looking at Connor, and Connor's like.
- I shouldn't discriminate
against her four amputees.
- Yeah.
- That's the end of that sentence.
- That's it, that's it.
I shouldn't, and I won't.
- They deserve sex too.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- As in Asanagi.
- Just imagining how you draw the panels.
Was it like, "We only have
an X amount of budget left,
get rid of the limbs."
- We don't have enough
time to draw the limbs.
It's coming out tomorrow.
- I think I'm afraid to ask,
but how you go about researching
how to draw the sex scenes for that?
- Well, I knew like a paraplegic,
so I talked to that person for a bit,
and like asked them,
how do you... you know.
- Is it awkward having to
ask them those questions?
- Okay, I didn't ask, like,
"How do you have sex?"
- Oh.
- They're like, "How do you fuck?"
- How do you go about
doing your daily life?
Like, what do you find hard to do?
How do you cope with not
being able to do this or that.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
So that's really interesting, yeah,
so you actually had to
interview your friend.
- [Shindo] Right.
- Just to give yourself
a frame of reference
to draw that.
- Right.
- If you didn't know someone
and you wanted to kind of ask them,
how would you, do you have
any way of doing that?
Like, if you wanted to meet someone
who is in a certain condition.
- I don't know, you'd have
to go on Reddit or something.
- "Any paraplegics here?
You wanna tell me how you fuck?"
- How often do you have to
do this kind of research
where you have to talk to someone
to see what their experience is?
- I mean, it's really
just for me, basically.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because I mean,
I figure you could do it
without doing the research
or without asking.
- Oh, I'm sure.
I've seen artists that
definitely do not do the research
for whatever they're drawing.
- Yeah.
- But, for me, it adds
a little bit of like...
I could add one thing that speaks true
to someone who's experienced it, maybe.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's like,
"Oh yeah, I know how that feels."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And if you had that one thing,
then it makes the story
a lot more interesting.
- Yeah, because I remember
when we did the interview
and I asked you about "Metamorphosis"
and I think you said, and
correct me if I'm wrong,
but the big reason why you
came up with Saki's characters
because you've heard of, knew people-
- I knew someone. Right.
- Who had similar experiences.
Right? And kind of lived through it.
- I knew a girl in high
school who got into drugs.
- Right.
- But it's not based on her or anything.
- Right, right, right.
But I'm sure it was like a lot
of it was kind of inspired,
or kind of taken from
that experience, right?
- Or,
you know someone who's been
through a lot of shit, and like,
and Saki's been through
like all the shit, right?
- Yeah.
- It's like, she had like
a comedically bad life.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- But if you take one aspect of it,
it could speak true to someone.
- Mm.
- Like, you know, yes, that part is...
I recognize that part as being real.
- Right.
- So that makes the story more engaging.
- Have you ever had anyone come up to you
at events or whatever, and being like,
"I really related to Saki's character,"
or, "I related to this
particular character,"
that spoke true to them.
- I get that a lot from Saki, especially.
- Oh yeah.
Damn.
- I feel bad now.
- Yeah, right.
It's heavy.
- No, I am curious,
because you said that you
had to sensor yourself
for "Metamorphosis",
because you were drawing it in a magazine.
- [Shindo] Right.
- I'm curious now,
will you ever release like
a director's cut, I guess?
- The Snyder cut?
- The Snyder cut.
- Like 500 pages.
- Because I guess, even
if you couldn't release it
in the magazine,
your audience worldwide now is vast enough
to be able to sell that to,
because I'd willingly pay money
to see a fucking director's cut
of whatever you had
planned originally, now.
- I know a lot of people
have been saying like,
"Oh, Shindo L should make the happy end."
- Right.
- For "Metamorphosis",
where she doesn't die.
- The Jojo end.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Jojo end.
- I think, yeah, I think it's me,
when I was reading it. I was like,
I think the one thing that
I was like, "Oh my god,"
is that it's so fast reading it,
all in one sitting.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Everything is like, boom, boom, boom.
Your life's ruined, your
life's ruined again,
and now your life is over.
And it's like, all right.
- No downtime, basically.
- Yeah, yeah, there's
literally no break at all,
and it's just like, you're
depressed, more depressed
and you're miserable, and
you're never recovering,
and it's like, "Oh, okay."
All right, I guess I'm sad now.
- Maybe that's something you
can do on your Patreon, right?
- Maybe.
I mean like the thing
about working in a magazine
or just even doing a doujin is like,
you have a certain amount of pages
and then you have to have
some action in there.
- Right. Right, right, right.
- So you can't like spend
a hundred pages, you know,
showing someone's life.
- Right.
- God forbid.
Oh my god, imagine no
fucking in that time.
I'll go bored.
- Have you ever thought about
just doing like a non H manga
or a non ero manga?
- I mean, I've thought about it,
but then I just come back
to, what it can be a hentai.
- Is that mentality of like,
anything can be a hentai.
- That's like a true culture.
- Yeah.
- So every story can be improved by sex?
- I mean, if you work it the right way.
- Yes.
- It's all in the execution.
- It's a powerful tool.
- Yes, yes, Connor. Yes.
- But I think you forgot
"Planet of the Apes".
This is the man that did it.
- When I watched "Planet of
the Apes", I didn't think,
"Man, I wanna see Caesar
just fucking go at it. "
- See that's the challenge, right?
- True, yeah.
- That's- that's-
- How do you make Caesar go?
- How do do you do that?
That's the mental stimulation, right?
- My god.
- I admire it.
I admire the determination to be like,
"I want to have sex in this."
- I want to try and find every scenario
and turn that into somehow having sex.
- Yeah.
- But like,
after like doing hentai,
then like, I don't know,
at first I thought, maybe I'll use it
as a stepping stone to do other stuff,
but the more I got into it, the more,
like the deeper the world got.
- Right.
- Like the hentai world.
- Yeah.
- And like,
I realized how much more
I could do in hentai,
then once I realized that it's like,
you don't have to like step out of hentai.
- Yeah.
- You can do
everything you want in hentai.
- What do you want to
do in the hentai world?
- Oh my god. Everything.
A sci-fi epic, maybe I could do that.
- A sci-fi epic. That sounds incredible.
- Oh man.
Shindo L looks up at the
night sky, and he's like,
"They could be fucking up there."
- "Legend of the Galactic
Heroes", except for more fucking.
- More fucking.
- Oh my god.
- "Legend of the Galactic
Heroes" should have more fucking.
- Yeah, definitely.
- It deserves to have it.
- Yeah.
- There's not enough fucking in space,
as far as I'm concerned.
- No, there's not. There's not.
- There's never been a
good zero G sex scene
so far in hentai.
- Yeah.
- You probably have to
research that though, right?
- Yeah, definitely.
- It's like,
what kind of different stimuli
would a person be able
to get while in zero Gs?
- There are the contraptions
that people have developed
to strap each other together.
- Right.
- Whilst they are in space.
- But it's never been tested.
- Like a real one?
- Yeah, in real life.
- Oh wow.
- People have been
thinking about this shit.
- Of course they have.
- And I've been
watching them think about it.
- It's like, "yes, I agree."
- Yeah.
- I'm like, "Hmm."
- [Joey] This is a great idea.
Oh my god.
- Is it hard to go... is
it like a normal thing
that maybe someone will do ero manga
and then just go back to doing manga?
Is that common in Japan, or is it kind of-
- There are people who do ero manga
then go on to do non ero manga.
- [Connor] Oh, okay.
- Some people come back.
- [Connor] Right.
- The author for "Sekirei"
was originally a ero manga person,
I think, or a doujin manga,
or like a...
"Shokugeki no Soma".
And "Shokugeki no Soma" as well.
- I think that guy
clearly wanted to do porn.
- Yeah, of course.
He did. No, he did.
- He did do porn.
- "Shokugeki no Soma" is basically porn.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Pretty much. Yeah.
- And "Nagatoro".
- "Nagatoro", yeah, the ultimate
"Nagatoro" was a doujin.
- Sakurai sensei, the
person who did "Ajin".
- Oh, oh really?
- Yeah, also.
- I didn't know that.
Oh, wow, so it's actually
more common than I thought.
- Yeah. It's very common.
- Do you get to hang out with
many other ero manga authors?
- Yeah, I mean, years
ago, like before COVID.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I used to go out
drinking a lot.
I used to go out drinking
with Asanagi sensei.
- I'd like to have been a
fly on the wall for that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And we just talk about
like how shit's going
and like, what do you
wanna do next Comiket?
What do you want next Comiket?
- So you were like, "Hear me out Asanagi.
I want a fucking in space."
- Yeah.
- The workers must be quite confused
over hearing your conversation.
"What?"
- "They're talking about
strapping themselves to each other
in zero Gs, and fucking."
- It's a very tight knit
community, the hentai community.
- How many authors, or
how big is the scene?
- Right. I have no idea.
If you take everybody into account,
there's like thousands of people.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- But if you take one
publisher, for example,
like sometimes they'll throw a party
and people will get together,
and all the authors would just
introduce themselves to each other,
build rapport,
and after that, sometimes
we'll just hang out.
So that's cool. You know?
- That's awesome.
- That's cool. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because like I've
interacted with Asanagi sensei
on Twitter, before, and it's so weird,
he is legitimately one of
the most wholesome dudes
I've ever interacted with on Twitter,
and I'm like, the dichotomy between
how wholesome he acts on
Twitter versus the shit he draws
is just nuts.
- Done or do anything with ero stuff.
Generally quite chill.
- Yeah.
- Again, I mean,
you must have some level of clarity.
You're not lying to yourself.
You're like, "I like this."
- Yeah, I think what makes
a lot of them so cool
is just the fact that it's
like, they have nothing to hide.
- Yeah.
- It's like,
I make shit like this. You
either love it or you hate it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And if not,
then I don't really care, kind of thing.
- Life's effect.
- Yeah. Yeah.
They've opened up all their chakras.
They just like, "I don't
even care anymore."
Yeah.
- I think hentai authors
or mangaka are really good
at separating their
fantasy and their reality.
- Mm.
- So like, you know,
you might be into lowly,
but in your life, of course, you're not.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Right, right.
- Yeah, that's good to hear.
- Like, yeah, thank god.
I mean, it wouldn't be much
of an industry, you know?
- You mentioned there's
thousands of doujin artists.
- [Shindo] Yeah.
- What percentage of that are
able to do it for a living?
- Oh, a fraction.
- 5%, 1%?
- Maybe like 10, 5%.
- Wow.
- Damn.
- Yeah, how do you see people
trying to stand out now?
- Oh my god, people
are so much better now.
- Oh really?
- Dammit.
- It's so much better now
than it was like 20 years ago.
- Right.
- Right, right, right.
- This keeps going up, and
it's because of skill inflation
that I can't keep up with.
- Skill inflation.
- It is insane.
You see people drawing
stuff on trains here,
and even then they're like, 10 years old,
and they're drawing anything better
than I'll ever accumulate to in my life.
- Yeah.
The the posts I hate the most on Twitter
is when a doujin artist
or an artist is like,
"Just a one hour sketch,"
and it's a fucking masterpiece of a thing.
I'm like, "I hate you.
Your art is are amazing,
but I goddamn hate you."
So I wish I could say that.
- It's the thing I see where
the only thing that
shows up in my timeline
is when artists do, "Oh,
a quick one hour sketch,"
and then they go, "Complete
the sketch," or something,
and it's just like a
10th of the interactions.
I was like, "What?"
How does this work?
- That's why they only post
work in process pics now,
because they're the only ones
that get any interaction.
- If you wanna be a successful
artist on Twitter now,
don't ever finish your work.
- Yeah.
- It's only post the sketches.
- I know a couple of guys who are just
so much better than me,
but they've never gotten like
the notoriety they deserve.
- Right, right, right.
- They can't make a
living on just drawing,
and so they have to work
second jobs, do their jobs.
- Yeah.
- It's really depressing.
- That's really sad.
- Yeah.
- What is the main way
artists make a living
or hentai artists make a living nowadays?
Is it still Comiket, or has
there been a big increase
in say, online Patreon, or other avenues.
- Online work has just blown up
in the past few years.
- Yeah. Mm-hmm.
- Of course.
- So I think the mainstream
now is just download,
like, Fanza and DLsite.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- I think is maybe more than
half the market, definitely.
- Right, right, right.
- Right.
Yeah, 'cause I've definitely seen,
especially in the last few years,
in the Western Twitter or
Western industry, I guess,
is there's been a huge explosion of-
- Patreon and stuff.
- Patreon,
especially even animators,
like hentai animators,
and especially 3D
artists, and 3D animators.
- People who make "Overwatch" porn
are the best animators in the world.
- Yeah.
- Pixar wish they could animate.
- Yeah. Right.
- Somehow they all just
decided "Overwatch"
would be the thing.
- I didn't know
you could animate 200 frames a second,
but that's right there.
That's as smooth as hell.
- Obviously, I've seen
like Western side of it,
but like on the Japanese side, is is like,
if you are one of the top artists,
is there a potential to
make a lot of money from it,
or is it still quite
limited on what you could?
- Oh man, I think if you
are one of the top artists,
I think nowadays, in the
past few years, of course.
I think having the online presence
is a lot more important
than it used to be.
- Right.
- Of course.
- So people have half a
million followers on Twitter,
or something.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I think they can
easily make as much money
as they want, I think.
- Why not? Right.
- Yeah.
- I have no idea.
- I mean, there's probably
also a lot of doujin artists
who have found success
because of their social media presence
by doing stuff that's not
necessarily doujin stuff.
- Mm-hmm.
- Because I think
Asanagi sensei started like illustrating
a regular manga series,
or like a light novel
series or whatever it was.
- There was illustrations
for novels and stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So there's a lot of light novels I know
where the illustrations
are done by doujin artists.
- Right, right.
- And a lot of people
know them from stuff like that, right.
Like Pochi, for example.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "Ane Naru Mono" was just
like so massive for him.
- Exactly.
- But even though...
for her, sorry, for her, but
even though she did that,
she still does doujin shit.
- Yeah.
- She's a VTuber now, I believe.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's the next step.
Every doujin artist is gonna be a VTuber.
- They always come back.
They always come back to porn.
- It has literally become the
plot of eromanga sensei now,
where they just livestream their work.
- [Joey] Exactly. Exactly.
- I gotta ask, 'cause I've been curious.
Maybe you can explain it.
- [Shindo] Right.
- What is up with those pesky black lines
that you see.
- Everywhere I look.
Everywhere I look.
- All I see.
All I see is the pesky black lines.
- I think now it's just
like a white splotch.
- Or like the white splotch,
or sometimes if the-
- Yeah, why does it keep changing?
- I think it's, well I know it's
some very complicated dance
with the powers that be.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- Because they'll come in
to a publisher especially
and say, "Too much."
- Right.
- Cut it back.
- Right, right, right.
- So, yeah.
- So you guys put as little
as possible to not anger
the people who make up the rules, right?
- Well, you know, the
publishers keep trying
to push the limits, but then
there's always push back.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- And when the Tokyo
Olympics were happening,
the build up to that was just
more and more censorship.
- Oh, right.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Right.
- I mean they got rid of
porn magazines from konbinis,
right, because of that.
- Yeah.
- They did?
That was one of the things
that the Tokyo government
decided to do, they were like,
"We're gonna have a lot of
people coming into Japan
and we don't want people
coming here for the first time
to walk into a family mart and be like,
'There's a lot of porn mags here.
Next to all the manga. That's...'"
- I never looked at them,
but I thought they were still there,
but I think it must just be
like lewd stuff then, I guess.
- It's the reviewer stuff.
- Yeah, there's a lot
of like reviewer stuff.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
But the actual porn magazines,
there was, usually there's a curtain,
separating those kinds of like
stuff, right, in anywhere,
but in konbinis, it was just there.
- Just there.
- In the open.
Usually right next to the toilet.
- Yeah.
- You know.
It's one of those things
where you go to the toilet
and you take a quick little peek
before you go to the toilet.
- I could tell
which ones there were, because
they were sellotaped shut.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You couldn't open them up.
- They're roped up, right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You will buy it.
Yeah, so that was one of the things
where they were just like,
we're just gonna eradicate porn mags.
- I didn't realize,
you hear from different
industries how kind of,
they went on like a blitz
before the Olympics,
to just try and clean things up.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Sanitize everything.
I mean they killed Airbnb.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I think they did a
few other things as well,
I can't remember those.
They did quite a lot of things.
They did so many things.
- They put a English signs up.
- Foreign pressure to just like clean up,
sanitize the whole hentai industry.
- Yeah.
- It was a shame really,
because it didn't really end up happening.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But it has happened, because
everything's more online now,
everything has to sort of
conform to Western markets,
- Global standards.
- Yeah, global standards.
- Right, right.
- Yeah, global standards,
so you can't have like,
there used to be a lot more bestiality,
but we can't have that anymore.
Used to be a lot more lowly,
you can't have that anymore.
There used to be shota, you
can't have that anymore.
- Yeah, so with regards to the censorship,
is there any rules that
have been put down on paper?
Let's say you have a penis or a vagina,
is there like a rule to like what part-
- 10% of the penis?
- Is there a rule of what
needs to be blocked out,
like 10%, 20%, or whatever?
- I think it depends on
what you're talking about,
because usually if someone's
putting a book out in Comiket,
the people who run Comiket
will come by in the morning,
check your book out, make
sure everything's censored
to the standards of whatever
the hentai industry's
doing at the moment.
- Right.
- So now things have to
be pretty blacked out.
- Right.
- But, you know,
10 years ago it used to be,
you have to have a bar over the tip,
you have to have a bar
over the little flange.
- That's the scientific term.
- Right.
And you have to have a bar
somewhere on the shaft.
- Right, right, right.
- Right.
- Like anywhere on the shaft?
- Somewhere, anywhere on the shaft.
- Oh, I've seen it just
in the most random places.
I was like, "That is doing nothing."
- It's like the middle of
the shaft, and it's like,
"I know what's behind that."
Yeah, I've always noticed
it's always the tip and the flange.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- But then there are some
instances where it's just like,
just seven lines over the entire shaft.
- Like a zebra.
- Yeah, it's like a zebra
cock, and it's like...
- So now it's more Minecraft looking,
completely blocked out.
- Yeah, it's like mosaicked,
but it's not fully mosaicked,
if that makes sense.
You can still make it out.
- I've seen a trend recently,
which is like the glowy dick.
- Oh yeah.
- The light saber.
- It's like, you can make a
faint outline of the cock.
It's somewhere around here.
- It's so weird whenever
you get that scene
whenever the girl takes off the trousers,
and it's just like, a glowing dick.
- Yeah.
- And it's just the most surreal thing.
I don't know who started this trend
or how this trend started, but yeah.
- I wanted to like make a scene
where the light source
is coming from that dick,
so it works with the
censorship, it's like...
- It's, there's no censorship here.
- Yeah.
- My dick just glows.
- Have you ever had to come
up with any creative ways
to come around to get past the censorship,
or anything like that?
- Well, the easiest thing
is just work at the angles
so you don't have to show as much.
- Right, right, right.
- Mm-hmm.
- I feel like, also, depending
on what angles you choose,
some are even better if
you don't just completely-
- Oh yes. Absolutely.
Sometimes it's just better
if you don't see anything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's paradoxical, but
sometimes like you don't-
- Less is more,
- Yeah, less is more.
Not seeing the faces sometimes
is sexier than seeing the face.
- Mm-hmm.
- Yeah, actually that's interesting.
How do you direct your own sex scenes?
How do you know what looks hot,
or is it just kind of like,
you look at other references
and you're like, "That
looks kind of good."
- There's a tempo to it.
You can't have like money
shot, money shot, money shot,
because it just blends all together.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So you need, downtime,
downtime, money shot.
- [Garnt] Right, right, right.
- Although I've read a lot of
doujins where it's just like
seven page mood of money shots.
It's like, bro, how has this
man's balls not exploded
at this point?
It's like, that's a lot.
- So you mentioned obviously
censuring from the government,
but is it ever hard when you're trying to,
dealing with almost self-censorship,
are you ever like, "Ah, is
this too much? I dunno."
- Well, personally, I try
to like push boundaries.
- Right, right.
- Like whatever makes
me feel uncomfortable,
sometimes I try to delve into that,
just to get a feeling for it myself.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Basically.
- Yeah.
Do you feel like that
uncomfortable feeling
enhances your story?
Is that what you would say-
- I think it makes it more
interesting, at least.
- But you're not doing it
purely for shock factor?
- It's not shock factor.
It's just to catch my own interest,
and it's not for any
deeper meaning, really,
but I mean, I think it
makes the work more-
- Unique.
- Unique, and-
- Spicy.
- A little spicy.
- Yeah.
I'm surprised that you said that the,
I guess, overseas norms,
affects the Japanese censors,
because normally people
are under the impression
that Japan doesn't give a fuck
what the outside world thinks.
- I mean, the standard anime industry
definitely is the case, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's strange if the anime
industry doesn't care,
but then I guess if to
hear that the ero stuff
kind of maybe is more affected
by what other countries think and what-
- I think maybe it's
'cause the doujin industry
actually cares for the
international community, maybe.
- Well even the normal anime stuff,
they're remaking "Urusei Yatsura", right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And one of the first
scenes is a booby shot.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like,
what's gonna happen?
Are we gonna conform to global standards,
or are we just gonna go with the a's.
You know?
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like complete remake.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I guess, when you make your work,
do you have to keep this
into account, or is it-
- I try not to.
- Yeah.
- Like, I don't know. It's fantasy, right?
So like (grimaces)-
- Yeah.
- It's gotta be annoying
to talk about, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean...
- Because you're like-
- Throughout this conversation
I've had this one before, more than once.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- How do you go about like
making something, and make it...
because you know it's
not socially acceptable.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- I think when it's art, right,
it has to be done tastefully
or appropriately, right,
for it to be like,
okay, you need to have
stories about stuff like this.
Because it happens, you know.
- Like I don't necessarily
personally agree with it,
but I'm okay with it existing.
- Because obviously as artist
and author, you don't...
your characters aren't you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They're there
to represent something
and to push a storyline,
and just because you
write about a story...
I don't really agree when people are like,
"You can't write about X topics."
It's like, no,
I mean, if this stuff
happens in real life,
it happens in real life.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Why shy away from it?
Horrible stuff happens all the time.
You should be able to
write a story about it.
Obviously, there are some people who do it
not tastefully at all.
- Yeah.
- Well the argument I hear a lot is that
it normalizes the act.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I disagree with that.
- No, I disagree.
- I disagree too, but I hear it a lot.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Hey guys, I was wondering
if you have a favorite fruit?
- I like strawberries.
- Oranges for me.
Why are you asking this all of a sudden.
- Well boys, because this
episode of "Trash Taste"
is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Bokksu?!
- I know a lot of you have
already signed up for Bokksu,
which is awesome, but for those
of you who aren't familiar,
Bokksu is a monthly
subscription snack box service
that delivers premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings
straight from Japan to your door.
Each Bokksu features a new theme,
providing a gourmet journey through Japan
every single month.
This month's theme is manatsu fruits,
which translates to in
English as "midsummer."
- There's a couple of things
you can get in this month's Bokksu,
including the mixed berry cake.
- Ooh, let me try that, Joey.
- This is the perfect combination
of light, airy and moist.
- Mmm. That's good, man.
- Well, the good thing is guys,
you can pair that with this Satsumarche
Sakurajima Komikan tea.
This green tea is flavored
with the peel of komikan,
a type of mandarin orange native
only to the Kagoshima prefecture.
The other one that I recommend
is the Marui Chinsuko pineapple.
Chinsuko are a traditional
Okinawan shortbread style cookie
with a crumbly, crunchy texture.
How's it taste, Connor?
- Yeah, that's good.
- Yeah?
- That goes so well
with the tea.
- We receive these boxes every month
and absolutely love them.
So if you want to try some
rare Japanese snacks with us
and support the channel as well,
then use our code Trashtaste15 at checkout
and the link in the description below
to save $15 off your first order.
- Back to the show.
- So, legitimate question.
- Okay.
- Dick girls.
- Yeah.
- Because, you know, it's
a thing, in doujins, a lot.
There's a lot of it.
- It's a thing.
- And you have a series, "TSF",
that has dick girls in it.
Right.
- I have a series, yes.
- I've always been curious,
how do doujin artists get into that?
- Are you not into it?
- I'm like half-half, into it.
I'm not crazy about it.
- What's the name of the tag, again?
- Dick girl.
- Is it just dick girl?
- Or futa.
- Futa, right.
- Yeah, yeah, futa.
- Futanari.
- Yeah, like futanari, right.
Because it's like, when you think
of stereotypical doujin tags,
futa is usually the first
one people think of, right,
because I feel it's very much like a-
- I think there was a poll
that FAKKU did, right,
of like the most popular search tags.
- Oh, per state.
- Per state, yeah.
And futa was like all over the US.
- Yeah.
- I think it's like,
yeah, I think I remember seeing that.
It was like out of like
outta like the 50 states,
I think it was like 41 states,
the most viewed tag was futa, yeah.
So it's like, it's just, I don't know,
it's just this really interesting thing
that I think it's just so
synonymous with the doujin world,
especially.
- Yeah.
- And a lot of people are so like,
again, it's like another
one of those things
like loli and shota, where
it's like a very clear divide.
Right, but and yet it's
like weirdly embraced.
- Yes.
- For some reason, right.
But you're not personally into it, right?
- No, personally, I'm not like,
it doesn't mean do anything for me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But I understand
intellectually how it works,
like, why it's appearing.
- I've hear someone
describe it intellectually.
- Intellectually.
- I appreciate it. I appreciate it.
- So I try to put it into the work
because I want to explore that aspect of-
- So what made you want to
explore that side of things?
- Well, you know, I've
never done it before.
I'm like, let's give it a try,
and the more I try work it,
then the more I understand why it works.
- Mm-hmm.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You know?
- So is your mission, I guess,
is to go through every
single tag to be like,
I'm gonna try and explore
every single one of these tags.
- I mean, like that's
a good goal, I think.
- That'd be cool.
- You're putting your
own twist on every tag?
- Yeah.
- That's a really good goal.
- Is there a tag you've seen
where you are just like,
"Whoa. What is that?"
- I'll tell you when I find it.
- Eye penetration.
- I've done it.
- What's the appeal of that?
- Like, it's...
- [Connor] Breaking laws of physics?
- Like, there's penetration-
- Breaking the taboo
of the law of physics.
- Like, there's eye penetration,
there's ear penetration,
there's belly button penetration,
and it all links to like.
- Sorry.
- Yeah, that made my stomach quiver.
- It's basically all what you call ryona,
which is like torture, basically.
- Right?
- What?
- Yeah, torture porn, right?
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's a really common tag, ryona.
- Really?
- Yeah.
There's a lot of it.
- I didn't know any of this,
this is completely all new to me.
- Yeah.
- I don't read-
- You innocent child.
- I don't read anything.
- It is a vast world out there.
- Yeah.
- I'm just thinking like,
how would you even,
how would you do this physically?
- Like the orbital
socket is like this deep,
so you can find maybe a way to do it.
- I mean, I mean, I think the point is
you can't do it, physically.
- So that's the appeal of it?
- Yeah.
- That's the appeal.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's like,
I don't wanna see it in real life,
I don't wanna try it in real life.
- Maybe if you were Mrs
Incredible, maybe you could?
- I mean, you know, that's
one way to do it, right?
- Well, you've just discovered a situation
in order to achieve that.
- I don't know how much "Incredibles" porn
you think there is out there.
- I think there's a lot.
- There's a lot.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I was gonna say, I mean, made of rubber
to make that work, realistically.
- Yeah, that's like the one thing
I've always wanted to a
doujin artist, is like,
when you find those
kinds of non vanilla tags
and stuff like that,
what is it about like
those non vanilla tags
that makes you want to draw about it
or write about it
or kind of try it out.
- Well, the easiest way to get into it,
if someone who is really talented before,
and it's like, you don't
fall in love with the act
or the tag itself,
but you fall in love with the artwork.
- Right, right, right,
- Right, right, right.
- So, I don't know if you
know who Gujira sensei is?
- I know the name.
- He does manga that's about reptiles.
- Okay.
- Oh yeah.
I think I've seen Gujira on Twitter, yeah.
- He does fem boys on his free time.
- Right, right.
- Right, right, right.
- And I've never been
into fem boys, right,
but just reading his stuff, it's like,
oh, it's so good.
Like, this fem boy's hot.
- Yeah.
- That's my exact experience
with Asanagi.
- Right.
- Because a lot of his
topics in his doujins,
I'm not crazy about to be honest,
like a lot of it's just
like, "Whoa, okay,"
but the art is just so good, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- That like,
I can't stop reading it.
I just look at it as like,
damn, he can fucking draw
people and situations
like action scenes, like
really fucking well.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And like,
I think I just appreciate
him on that aspect,
and I think it's like,
I appreciate a lot of doujin
artists just for that aspect,
just for the fact that a lot of them
are just really talented artists.
- Right. Right.
- And it's like,
if I could draw like that,
I would absolutely fucking draw that shit.
You know?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like, why wouldn't you?
It's just cool. I don't know.
I say this because I can't draw for shit.
- If you could draw porn,
is that what you're saying?
- Huh?
I mean, look.
- I'm just trying...
- If I had the talent to draw porn.
- Okay.
- Why would you not?
- I mean, especially what they
were doing in the churches,
that's what they had.
- Right?
- A lot of the time.
- It's like, if I had the
talent to be able to draw
a really hot sex scene,
I would absolutely draw my own sex scene.
- Yeah.
- Because that's just like a power,
it's like, I don't even have
to look for porn anymore.
I'll just fucking make it.
- I'll make it.
- I will make the porn myself.
- Thanos like, "Fine."
- "I'll do it myself."
Yeah, exactly. I mean,
that's why you do it, right?
- Yeah, that's why I do it.
- Yeah.
Because it's like, you look around
and you're like, nothing
there that just clicks for me.
- Yeah.
- So I'll just do
exactly what I want to see, and
what I think is cool, right?
- Yeah.
- So it's like,
yeah, if I had the ability to do that,
I'd fucking do that in a heartbeat.
Absolutely.
- So like, what are some
of your favorite tags,
out of curiosity?
- I think some of my most
well known favorite tags
are like pregnant one.
- Right.
- Sometimes birth, sometimes like-
- What is birth?
- Birthing. Birthing.
- Birthing a baby.
- Was that in the show? In the thing?
- In the thing.
- Well, I mean "Metamorphosis"
had one, right?
- Well-
- Did it?
- No, not really.
- Not really, but kind of.
- It wasn't like a baby.
- I don't know much, so this is-
- But if you read "Shindo
L's Cultural Anthropology",
there's one chapter
it's all just birthing.
Plus, I wanted to.
- Just giving birth?
- Just giving birth.
- Okay.
I'm trying to process this.
- I hear the cogs just like, "Okay."
- I was just looking at
Connor when he said, "Okay,"
and just the eyes darting
around, like, "Okay."
- I wanna ask questions,
but I'm scared to know the answer to some.
- Just ask.
You want to have an opportunity? Just ask.
- Just ask. Yeah.
- So, the pregnant thing I can understand,
I can understand that could be attractive.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- But what about the birth
aspect is attractive?
- Well, why not go a step
further when you go...
If you're into the pregnancy already,
then why not go a step further?
- This is watching, that's
the attractive part.
- Well, you know, just, well...
- Okay. Okay.
I was just making sure I understand now.
- You can be like, I mean,
you could theoretically do
anal while you're doing it,
but like, you know, doesn't have to.
- I guess you could. Yeah.
- That is indeed a fact.
- The laws of physics allow
it, no other required.
- I feel a pattern, which is just like,
well, you theoretically could do this, so-
- I think what I'm learning is that
it's asking the questions
that men never asked
and then you're like, "Let's
fuck it, let's do it."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Let's give it a go.
- I admire the exploration.
- Yeah.
- Okay, carry on. What
other tags, what other tags?
- Ishukan, which is cross species.
- Okay. That makes sense.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You know, usually mixed in
with pregnancy and birthing.
Right.
- Right.
- Mm-hmm.
- Okay.
- Gotta just like, "Why not?"
- Why not?
How many sauces can you
put on the hot dog, dude?
- It's like a chef, right?
Just like the ingredients.
- Okay. Okay.
- And, well, you know, the normal stuff,
like gang bang, whatever,
you know?
- Yeah.
- So it's like vanilla, can you
just not do vanilla anymore?
- I can do vanilla. Sure, why not.
- Go back to the classics, eh?
- Like, the Broly one was vanilla.
- Was it?
- Wasn't it?
Wasn't it?
- I wouldn't...
- There's two people, and
they're just there doing a thing.
- I mean...
- Does vanilla not excite
you to create works?
- No, it's not vanilla, because
there was a birth scene.
- What's..?
- There was.
- How is birth not vanilla,
though?
- This man's living on a
different level of reality.
He's like...
- I think your version of vanilla and mine
is so far gone.
I'm missionary, go to bed
at 9:00 PM, watch a TV show.
That's vanilla.
- Like, the natural outcome of that.
- No, actually, so nothing
quote unquote, unnatural, right?
- Right.
- This is just
standard human experience.
Okay, that makes sense.
- No, but I get that,
but it's just the fact that you're like,
"What's not vanilla about birth?"
It's just like, it's like third eye open.
It's like, "Oh my god, you're right."
This man's like another plane of reality.
- Just a brain expansion.
It's just like, couples
getting together, vanilla.
- So it's like an attractive
thing to see just a baby born?
- I mean, because the mother
has to go through all these stages, right?
- Yeah.
- Oh,
and that's the attractive part, watching-
- That's attractive.
- Okay. Okay.
I think I understand.
I think.
- I feel like
you need to read some of it.
- Yeah, I think I need-
- To like figure it out.
- I should research all this.
What other tags? I'm interested.
Cross species. Okay.
- Cross species.
- That one makes sense
to me. That seems hot.
- Yeah.
- Well, I mean, yeah.
"Ishuzoku Reviewers" was fucking massive.
- "Ishuzoku" are hot. Why not?
- I know. Yeah.
- Exactly, exactly.
- I mean technically,
the Broly one was also-
Yeah. That's-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
- But normally, we're talking
about non-human cross-species.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What else? You know, the normal stuff.
Like, you know, transgender.
- Yeah. Right, right.
- Is one that I've been doing a lot.
What else have I been doing?
Well, you know, I do ryona
too, the torture stuff.
- Right, right, right.
- Just once in a while.
I recently did a collaboration
with Asanagi sensei
and he did his compilation
of various artists
doing girls who've had
their limbs got off.
- Right.
- Okay. Yeah.
- I feel sorry for the FBI agent
watching your search history.
I gotta say, the guy's
probably seen some stuff.
- He's like reaching
for his third notebook.
Yeah, write that one down too. Fuck.
I have to go through all this shit later.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I haven't done too much scat.
- Right.
- Except like vomiting,
vomiting I do a lot.
- Why?
- I mean, like...
- I'm genuinely curious, genuinely.
- I don't know, it's like, it's...
- I'm not trying to be like derogatory.
- One of the moments where
you feel at your lowest,
when you're throwing up.
- Okay.
So there's kind of an
attraction to seeing people
at a very low point, struggling.
- At a very vulnerable point.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, okay.
- I mean, yeah, so I
guess on the same level,
in terms of vulnerability,
it's similar to "Metamorphosis", right?
Very vulnerable.
- Yeah.
- Just in different ways.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
It's the same emotion, I guess,
just in a different kind of scenario.
- I just love that,
just if you just took that
conversation outta context,
it's like, "I do vomiting quite a bit,"
and you just going, "Why?"
That must be so weird
outta context, you know.
- I'm trying to understand.
- This one episode has
been like a gold mine
of just outta context clips.
- Yeah.
- Out of context clips.
- You know, because I like
to think that the podcast
is something where, even if we disagree,
like I said earlier,
it's something where we
can come to understand
and kind of talk and share,
even if I completely be like,
"That is fucked up. I
don't wanna know about it."
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I still think that you should
be able to tell me about it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And talk to me, and be
like, this is what it is,
and I'll be like, "Oh god.
Go ahead, king. Go on."
- I just want you to keep going
purely just to see Connor's reactions.
- This entire podcast
has just been golden.
Every so often, you'll say something
and Connor's just like, "What?"
- And every time you say
something that I know is fucked,
I immediately look at Connor.
- There's a lot of people who
would kill to be in this chair
and talk to you about this,
so I don't wanna squander that
opportunity by being like,
"No, I don't wanna know
anything about it."
I wanna learn about it so that I can-
- You can live vicariously.
- Yeah, yeah.
And if you don't know anything,
maybe you can learn by my
reaction to this episode.
- I'm living vicariously
right now, like Connor,
because I'm just like,
at least I know Connor's gonna have
a more fucked up reaction than me, right.
- I'm sitting on this side
of the table and I'm like,
sometimes I feel like
I should be over there.
- I love hentai, right. Hentai's great.
Me and Samuel L Jackson
have a lot in common.
- Yeah.
- And...
- Both cultured.
- I've lived in that clip,
I'm gonna to the grave with that.
"You don't like hentai? Well
Samuel L Jackson likes hentai."
And it almost feels like
hentai is so goddamn vanilla
from what's going on
in the doujinshi world.
- It is, it is.
- I watch a lot of the
hentai, and I feel like,
what is happening over there?
I feel like we're like the villa,
and you guys are fighting
down on the streets.
I'm like, "What's going on down there?"
- One thing I can definitely
say after talking to you,
is that, I think I have vanilla taste.
- Yeah.
- I never thought I would say
that, about previous hentai.
- I used to say vanilla,
that's lame as fuck,
but now I think I'm vanilla.
- Your colleagues, presumably,
don't all draw or cover
the same stuff as you.
Are they ever like, "Bro, chill."
- Oh no, no.
- Daddy chill.
- You're doing what now?
- No.
- It's always...
- What?
- I don't know what.
- Okay. Okay.
- I mean,
it's always fun to see what
other people are doing.
- Right, right.
- Right. Yeah.
- "Oh, you're doing that? Cool."
- I can imagine it can
be like, "Yes, king."
- Yes.
- "You fucking buff that king.
Yes."
- "Penetrate that eye, yes."
- I think when they made me read doujins,
they picked ones that were kind
of normal, I think actually
after hearing this.
- Yeah.
- This was probably the
one most left field for me.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Here's the next doujin episode.
We're gonna ask you to
recommend us some doujins
and we'll read it and talk about it.
- Actually, that would pretty fun.
- That'd be pretty fucking awesome.
- I'm gonna hate my life.
- Well if you're going
through my category,
then I suggest doing "Shindo
L's Cultural Anthropology".
- Okay.
- Because I had the most fun
writing that one.
- Okay.
- So that's you just explaining
all the genres, I guess?
- It's me playing around
with a lot of genres.
- Okay. Okay.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's like short stories?
- Oh no, it's one
continuous, it's episodic.
- Okay.
- Right.
- So a set of characters
doing different things every chapter.
- Okay.
- See a lot of these are
really confusing for me
because I'm like, am I
supposed to jack off?
I don't know when.
- Maybe you're not supposed to.
- Yeah.
- Am I supposed to be?
Genuinely? I don't know.
- No, I think it's just a matter of like,
if you think the time is right.
- Yeah, it depends on how you write it.
You are like, if you wanna just
read this and experience it,
do it, or are you writing it for like,
alright, you can go do it.
- I mean, some things
I've been thinking about
for a little while and, okay,
I kind of let it like percolate.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- And then like I put it on paper,
but other things, it's on a whim.
- Yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- That makes sense.
- I think, yeah,
'cause I don't jack off
to every doujin I read.
- Yeah.
- No.
- Sometimes I just like reading it
because I like reading it.
- Yeah.
- I just watch porn
yeah, I just watch it.
The storylines are good.
- No, but that's the weird thing.
- Sometimes it's an obligation.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But that's the weird thing, right?
I'm not like that with
like porn or hentai.
- Mm-hmm.
- So like what is it, I don't know,
it's there's this something
about doujins where it's like,
it can literally just be
like a pickup and read thing,
sometimes.
- Yeah.
- I see people on the train
just swiping through doujins.
- Yeah, sure.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm just like, "This
is a strong world, man."
This is rush hour.
- But I just find that
really fascinating, that
doujins can do that.
- Yeah.
- Where it's like,
even though you look at the contents of it
and you're like,
"Yeah, I can definitely see
someone jacking off to that,"
the fact that you can sometimes be like,
"Yeah, you know what,
I wanna read it, but I don't
really wanna jack off to it.
I just kinda wanna read it."
- I wanna read the
"Planet of the Apes" one.
- Yeah.
- That's not to jack off.
I'm just fascinated.
- Just curious, right?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I think it's, do you know why?
It's just gonna be so simple.
I think it's because doujins
aren't a hands free experience.
Right? Right?
If you choose to jack off
to a doujin, it is effort,
because you are holding something.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Whether it's like,
you're like juggling a lot of things.
You're juggling hentai,
you can put that on the TV.
- At least now you can
put it on the screen,
back in the day you had
to find a way to put that-
- Hold the book.
- Yeah, hold the book.
- Even if you put on the screen,
you've got to turn the
page or whatever, you know.
It's not a complete hands free experience.
- Next page.
- Yeah.
- My gosh.
- I've always been curious,
can you view porn in the same way,
or do you just view it now
as completely just research,
or something that you can
incorporate into your own words?
- Oh no, I could still, totally.
- Okay. Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's all good.
- That's when you know it's good, right?
That's when you know.
- You're like, "Finally,
some good fucking food."
- Is it more you prefer to read or watch?
- I'd rather read.
- Oh, that's interesting.
For me it's like the complete...
I do not wanna read it.
- I'm a manga person
rather than anime person.
- Right, right, right.
- Ah.
- So it's more about like
visualizing it, kind of.
- Right, it always works better in my mind
when I'm reading it.
- I guess that way it's
like, "I'll do it myself."
- It's like reading a novel
instead of watching a movie.
- Yeah, because you can fill
in the blanks in your own way,
right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you can make it a lot more sexy
or more for your taste than
perhaps the author intended.
- Right. Right.
- Whereas with hentai, it's
like, you get the full package,
and you can't really
change that, you know?
- Yeah.
- So I get it.
- I guess, is there anything
else you guys wanna ask
about hentai specifically,
because I think we need a
kind of chill down section.
- All right, let's do a chill section.
- What up, it's your boy, Joey,
here to let you know that
this episode of "Trash Taste"
is sponsored by Tippsy Sake.
You know, I'm traveling right now
and as the resident sake enjoyer,
I miss the good sake
that Japan has to offer,
but luckily, thanks to Tippsy,
I can have good Japanese sake
wherever I am in the world.
Tippsy, for those of you who don't know,
is a quarterly subscription box
that curates all sorts of
sake straight from Japan.
Because as we all know,
Japan is full of all
sorts of different sake,
and the world of sake
really does run quite deep.
In fact, let me show you
guys what kind of sake
you will be expecting for this quarter.
We have the Junmai Ginjo Bijin Okarakuchi.
This particular brew
gives an aroma red apple
that fades to an almost nutmeg spice.
It's a very dry sake,
said to be strong enough to kill a devil.
But if you want something
a little lighter,
then why not try the Jinoene Junmai Ginjo?
This sake is bursting with enticing aroma
and pristine flavor,
with hints of freshly sliced
apple and a crisp finish.
And that's just a couple of them.
There are a bunch of other curated sake
for you guys to enjoy,
different pairings, and taste testings
and stuff like that.
So if you wanna explore the world of sake
and are interested in checking it out,
then make sure to go over to Tippsy.
Link's in the description below.
And not only that, for
you "Trash Taste" viewers,
you can use our coupon code Trashtaste10
to get 10% off all your products.
But wait, that's not all.
In fact, if you use our other
coupon code, Trashtaste30,
you can get $30 off
your first sake bottle.
That is a steal.
So thank you again to Tippsy
for sponsoring this episode.
Onto the show.
- Yeah, so you were talking
about "Elden Ring" earlier.
- Oh yes.
- And being
a massive souls fan.
- Mm.
- So yeah, what are some
games or some anime, or...
What, Joey, what?
- I just love that it took us two hours
to get to this topic.
- I just want a normal conversation
just to like chill out for a bit.
It's been an intense two hour conversation
about porn so far.
I just wanna chill out for a while.
- I get it. I get it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, what are some like
games and anime that you like?
- Are looking forward to? Or like?
- Or just like in general? Yeah.
What are some of your other interests?
- Everything.
I like RPGs in general.
- Yeah.
- I like strategy games.
Like, if you've played
"Valkyria Chronicles".
- Oh.
- Yes, yes.
- I love that series.
- Yes. Yes.
I'm just getting into "Valkyria
Chronicles" right now. Yeah.
- It's a great series.
- Yeah.
- I mean, you're obviously
into "Dragon Quest"
and stuff like that.
- "Dragon Quest".
I love "Dragon Quest".
- Yeah.
- There's a new "Dragon
Quest 3" remake coming.
- Oh yeah.
- To talk about.
- Yeah, I wanna play that as well.
- What else is coming out?
Oh, there's a, what is it,
"Made in Abyss" action RPG coming out.
- Where?
- Is there actually?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- An action RPG?
- On PlayStation 4?
- It's rated Z for adults only.
- Oh.
- I wanna play that now.
- And I'm like, I'm
just curious, you know.
- But I'm always scared of anime games
'cause they haven't had
the best track record.
- Yeah, I mean, it's probably
gonna be shit to play,
but like-
- Yeah.
- You know, I'm interested.
- Yeah, sure.
- What can they possibly do?
- So you like "Made in Abyss"?
- I do love it.
- You know what, now that you say it,
it makes so much sense, right.
Because I'm just like, damn,
that definitely explores some topics
that I don't normally get to see.
- Right.
- Like, because-
- "Made in Abyss" is some ryona, right?
There's a lot of torture scenes in there,
I'm just like, "Oh god."
- That definitely makes
me feel uncomfortable.
- Yeah, definitely. Jesus.
- That makes a lot of sense.
Holy shit.
- Yeah.
What are like some standard
manga that you would recommend
or that you really, really like?
- Well, you know, now "Spy Family" is big.
- Of course.
- And I'm more
of a manga "Spy Family" guy.
- Mm-hmm.
- What else is new?
- That was just like the
most wholesome thing.
That did surprise me.
I was like...
- I dunno why that was a part of me
that was like, "Spy Family", too vanilla.
I was expecting it to be
like, " Yeah, so "Berserk".
- "Oyasumi Punpun".
- Love that shit.
- Just like suffer porn. You know?
It's just hilarious to imagine
you reading "Spy Family"
and being like, "Hell yeah."
Oh, it's so cute.
Yeah.
- So what's kind of like
some of your favorites
of all time, then?
- Oh my favorites of all time.
- Like, anime, manga, or video games.
- Anything drawn by Obata
Takeshi is amazing, of course.
- Oh, okay.
- Of course.
- Anything drawn by Murata
Yusuke is amazing, of course.
- Oh my god.
- The godly art.
- We're all fanboys of Murata Yusuke.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, his recent work of like
"One Punch Man", especially,
is just fucking incredible.
- Oh my god, it's amazing.
- And obviously "Eye Shield" as well.
- I don't know how that
man keeps improving.
- Yeah.
- It's crazy.
I thought he peaked at "Eye Shield 21".
- Yeah.
- And then "One Punch Man"
was like, "I could do better."
- It's crazy.
- Crazy good.
- Yeah.
Obata Takeshi, as well.
That's definitely another one
where I can definitely see it.
It kind of like makes sense,
'cause like he also has
like a really darkish style
and especially in like some
scenes in "Death Note",
back in the day it was like, whoa,
this isn't shown in "Jump".
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like, holy shit.
- Yeah.
- Like, I definitely remember
reading "Death Note" the first time
and I just, I didn't even
know it was "Shonen Jump".
- Yeah.
- You know.
I knew at that time what kind of manga
was kind of in "Shonen Jump",
you had like your Dragon
Balls, your Hakushos,
all that kind of thing, and
then you go to "Death Note",
and you're like, "This comes
from the same magazine?"
- Yeah.
- What?
- It looks like a seinin,
and it feels like a seinin.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So it's like,
yeah, I remember like-
- Walls of text, right?
- Yeah.
It's like a novel.
- I just can't imagine reading it
and not having like
the fucking Elves theme
playing all the time.
- Well, that's how people
experience it before the ending.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah, I know.
but like now I can't
think about "Death Note"
without having that song in my head.
- I know. Yeah.
- It's so iconic. Holy shit.
The anime's so good.
- Yeah, because like,
I remember when I first
saw that being adapted,
because that was one of
the few mangas I read
before watching the anime,
and I was just like,
there's no way this is
gonna work in anime form.
There is too much
dialogue, there's people-
- It's too stylized.
Just eating potato chips. How?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it blew my mind that I was just,
the anime was just that
engrossing where I just thought
there was no way you
could be able to translate
all of this text going on into
an interesting anime form.
- But they did it.
- But they did it. Fucking...
- Whoever directed that
was like five head, dude.
Like, they clearly knew
how to like take text based
and just very still visuals,
and make it visually exciting.
- Yeah.
- You also mentioned you'd put
many hours into "Elden Ring".
- Yeah, about almost 200. I think.
- Jesus Christ.
- Yeah, I got like 70 hours in it.
It's so good.
- Yeah.
- These boys haven't played
yet, for some reason.
I don't know why.
- Holy shit.
- It's because I'm trying
to find time to do it.
Because I know, I know I've
played enough FromSoftware games
where I'm like, "I know
I'm gonna love this game."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But I also have commitments as well.
- Yeah, and I need to block
out a week from my schedule.
- At least.
- It's just something,
there's something so amazing about
when that health bar
pops up on the screen.
On the bottom.
Yeah, I dunno what it is that
gets me so excited every time.
Like, every single time.
- [Shindo] Yeah, of course. Hyped up.
- It's so hyped.
- Let's go.
- So hyped.
What a game, dude.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- What about some video games,
aside from "Elden Ring"?
I mean, I suppose you've
been playing "Elden Ring"
a lot recently.
- A lot of "Chorus", always great.
- Never played FPS games,
or anything like that?
- Oh yeah, I played "Apex"
when I first came out.
- Oh, really? Okay, okay.
Me too, me too. I love "Apex".
- I played, I think last
"Battlefield" I played
was 3, though.
- Oh, "Battlefield 3".
I mean it's been a buggy mass ever since.
- Yeah.
- 3 was kind of-
- 3 was borderline, you know.
- Yeah.
- It's like,
I could accept this.
- "Bad Company 2" was really good.
That was a good "Battlefield" game.
God, okay, so you're a gamer. Good, good.
- Yeah.
- He's a gamer.
- Yeah, how much time do you have
to pursue your other hobbies
outside of your work?
Because you hear some horror
stories about manga artists
just having zero time.
- Mm-hmm.
- I mean, if you are working,
if you're doing a monthly or
weekly, then you have no time.
- Mm-hmm.
- For it.
- But I guess you do
like bimonthly, right?
- I do bimonthly, but now I'm
just taking long hiatuses.
Just because I bought a house,
and I'm fixing it up and gardening.
- [Connor] Okay. Nice.
- Gardening and doing
other retiree things.
- Right.
- But you know, I want
spend more time drawing.
- Spend more time drawing
eye penetration stuff.
- Exploring the darkest
depths of the human psyche.
- Need to get my priorities
straight, you know?
- Yeah, right.
That's what it all comes back to, baby.
All comes back to that.
- Yeah.
- Do you ever get inspiration
from works outside,
just from like normal manga,
that you find elements
that you can incorporate
into your work?
- Yeah, I mean, if you
look at like a sex scene,
it's basically an action scene.
So if you read battle manga,
there's a lot of angles and movements.
- I agree.
- Okay.
- Because I can never tell
what the fuck is going on,
in both, in both I'm like, "Why is that?"
- Yeah, so... okay.
Can you expand... like, what...
- I get it. I get it.
I get it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you're basically depicting movement.
- Right, right, right.
- Mm-hmm.
- So how do you get that
across on a still image, right.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- So, you do like in and out, in and out.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's like one way to do it,
but if you read battle manga,
you could incorporate in
and out in one picture.
- Teleports behind.
- Right, right.
- And it's just-
- I'll go, I'll go.
- So what about like the
pacing and tempo of a battle?
Does that play into factor?
I've never thought of it like that.
- [Joey] Yeah, I've never
thought of it like that. Yeah.
- Like, this is so
fucking interesting to me.
- I'm glad you said that,
'cause I actually always thought that.
- Really?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I just thought that sex scenes
were just battle scenes.
- You just think that
because "Baki" said so.
- Maybe.
- "Baki" was right, apparently.
- I'd argue the greatest
fight scene in "Baki"
is the sex scene.
- Because the tension of a fight
feels the same as the
tension of a sex scene.
- Mm-hmm.
- That's true.
In a lot of ways. Yeah.
The tension in a good fight scene
and the tension of a good sex scene
is like for none, it's exactly the same.
- Yeah, I guess I'm so
curious to hear what, like,
what does that breakdown into?
Are you talking about just
movement or just the tempo
or the pacing or?
- Paneling and movement,
like let's say you're having a sex scene.
Right?
- Right.
- And you'll notice there's a large panel.
- Yeah.
- Something happening,
and there'll be a small panel
of some guy flipping his wrist.
- Right.
- And then the next scene
you'll see how he's using that as his hand
in a different way.
- Right.
- And it's the same
thing in a battle manga.
- Right.
- One guy's fighting,
but then he does a small movement
and you'll see the small
panel where they show that,
and then that gets incorporated
into the next scene.
It's a scene.
- Oh, okay.
That's so interesting.
- Like it's kind of creating
a flow, right, of movement.
- Yeah.
- So do you like,
when you are drawing this,
do you have like kind of
like a rough storyboard
in your mind about how the
paneling is going to be?
- Do you sketch it out beforehand?
- I sketch it out beforehand.
- Right.
- But, you know,
there are different,
you have different templates in your mind.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- And you go by those templates
and then once in a while
you wanna change it up.
- Yeah, yeah.
- To make it interesting.
- [Garnt] Right, right, right.
- So I think the more experience you have,
the more templates you have in your mind.
- Right.
- So it doesn't
become monotonous.
- Okay. Okay.
That's so in.
Yeah, because I've never
thought of it like that,
but now that you've said it out loud,
it makes so much sense.
- Everyone saw the moment
where it just clicked in Garnt's mind.
He's like-
- You can see the light bulb,
just like, "Oh."
- Dude, Garnt's gonna be
watching like "Demon Slayer"
getting bricked up.
- Damn, that flow of movement, though. Oh.
- So you're telling me, you
prefer it to animate sex scenes,
it's just gonna be the
greatest... the greatest-
- The greatest fight of all time.
- It's the greatest fight, yeah.
- Back in the '90s you had
top animators doing hentai.
- Yeah, yeah. I know, I know.
- Not so much these days, but
back in the day it was like,
we had big names, you know?
- Yeah, unfortunately we
have Queen Bee nowadays.
- [Shindo] Yeah.
- But yeah, I do know that
hentai back in the day had some,
in terms of animation studio
and animation work on it,
it was like some big, big names.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- Sakuga.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sakuga.
- You laugh but that
was a thing back then.
- It was just funny hearing him say that.
I'm a child.
- Dude, the Sakuga '90s hentai is insane.
- It is insane.
- It's crazy, yeah.
- And now it's like very much
the same kind of glossy look.
- [Shindo] Right.
- The same kind of template.
There's less-
- Now we're back to drawing
a frame, and then just moving
it on camera like this.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, it's not all like that,
but there's definitely
less experimentation.
- Right, but now you have amateurs
who are doing amazing animation work.
- Yeah.
- Just on their own.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like the one
in the Italian Senate.
- Yeah, yeah. The "Tifa" one.
- The "Tifa" one.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was very impressive.
- Yeah, like I said,
some of the most impressive hentai work-
- I think we're going full circle,
we have a lot of talent working in,
just doing sex scenes now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And, you know, hopefully
it'll keep going that way.
- Yeah, because some of
the most talented artists
and talented animators
I've seen in the porn world
has been independent, you know,
and I'm just like, damn.
what if I saw like...
'cause normally you only get to see
a minute or two of animation,
which is of course as much as
you're gonna be able to see
from one person, but I'm just like,
man, what if he had like
an actual 30 minute episode
that actually looks like this.
That would be insane.
- Give that man some money.
- Yeah, yeah. Right, right.
- Give this man a studio, right now.
Give him a production.
- That would be amazing.
- Yeah.
Anyway, I don't have anything more to ask.
- Me neither, man. I think
I've been in action today.
- I'm full. I'm full.
There was so much good food here.
- I'm enlightened. I am
just fulfilled right now.
Oh, one last question.
- Okay.
- Is hentai art?
- Yeah.
- Okay. Okay.
I thought we knew this.
- Now no one can argue on Twitter.
Confirmed right here.
- Where can they find you, and also.
what should they be looking out for?
- You can find me on Twitter.
You can see, go to dahootch.com,
I have a website there,
and my next project,
aside from artwork I do for a mobile game
called Taimanin RPG.
- Oh, okay.
- I'm still working on a
project for Comic Unreal,
which is going to be
a fantasy epic, maybe.
- Oh wow.
- Hopefully.
- Awesome.
- Yeah, right.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, well the links to all those
in the description below, as always.
- And you said you had a Patreon as well?
- And I have a Patreon.
- The Patreon. Yeah.
Support him on Patreon.
- Yes.
- What's the URL for that
Patreon, or username, I guess.
- ShindoL, I think.
- Is it just ShindoL?
- Yeah. so links in the description.
Hey, speaking of Patreon,
look at our Patreon.
- Yeah.
- Oh wow. Cool.
- Look at all of them on
screen right now. Amazing.
- Look at all these cultured
individuals right now.
- But yeah, if you would
like to support the show
and also watch the uncensored
version of this episode,
because god knows we're
gonna get monetized now.
- They got this far.
- I mean, either way, if you
like to support the show,
then go off to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste,
also follow us on Twitter,
send us memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify,
and of course, go check
out Shindo sensei's stuff.
Links in description.
Yeah, thanks for coming.
- Thank you.
- The enlightenment was unreal.
- I've learned a lot.
I've learned a lot today.
- We are gonna leave
this office different men
after this episode.
- I do, I feel enlightened.
- I'm never going to look
at an eyeball the same way.
Thank you so much, man.
- Yeah, thank you for coming.
- Thank you.
- And thank you guys.
- It's been an incredible episode.
- And thank you guys for watching.
- Yeah.
- See you guys next time.
- Bye.
(exhausted music)